there's no time
[Music]
13. o'clock
[Music]
hey you guys what's going on it's us
again what the hell day is it it's
Wednesday that's when it's the main show
yeah Wednesday this is going to be a
good show tonight uh this is this is a
good topic we're going to do uh Reverend
moon and the Moonies yeah what's it
called something rather unification
certification Church unification sure
you're trying to unify everything he's
the only man that [ __ ]
single-handedly uses psychic abilities
destroyed the Soviet Union
yeah yeah I mean in the astral plane
yeah like we said it's it's really easy
to say you like you did some ass kicking
yeah yeah
it's pretty good
it's a crazy crazy story I mean all you
know what I actually didn't I didn't
know a huge amount about them like I
knew a little bit but I was like doing
research about it and I was like in some
aspects even though they are very very
uh Christian they are they are also kind
of like a lot like Scientology yeah they
are very very similar in some ways
they're into psychic abilities and stuff
too yeah well they're real into like
spiritual spiritualism and they think
you can like Channel dead people and all
that kind of stuff but I just meant from
the point of view of scientologists like
having a whole bunch of front groups
that you don't actually know are
associated with them having like a [ __ ]
ton of money like diversifying into lots
of different
um you know kind of fields uh you know
so they own like loads and loads of
businesses and loads of other things
that you might not know are associated
with them
um uh yeah and honestly it's weird
because like some groups which I'll
mention a few of them later
um they give money to the same groups as
Scientology does you know what I mean
it's really interesting like some of the
parallels wait hold on restate that some
groups gives money no I said no I I was
trying to say like two sentences okay at
the same time okay and you missed the
middle yes
I was saying some of the groups yeah
that that uh the Moonies give money to
are the same groups that Scientology
okay gives groups
okay but nobody owns them but well yeah
but the thing about it it's just like
you know how like Scientology is like
narcanon and it has like all those like
the Moonies are like that too except
maybe more so okay because uh yeah the
Moonies own
I feel like it's funny because I didn't
even realize like I knew some of the
[ __ ] like I knew they owned the
Washington times and I knew all that
kind of stuff but
um some of the groups I was like huh
that's really interesting they own all
kind of [ __ ] and a lot of it is in Asia
but a lot of it's over here too and I
think that really people
I feel like if you said it before 2022
because I think they got back in the
news in 2022 because of the
assassination of uh Shinzo Abe the
former Japanese prime minister which had
some ties in with this cult
um so they kind of came back into the
Forefront then and I think people
started looking more into like all the
Shady kind of [ __ ] they were doing
behind the scenes but I think prior to
that if you'd said anything about it
um you know people be like oh that's the
one with the weird like Mass weddings
and stuff like that which it is but they
have all kind of like [ __ ] political
[ __ ] and all this other kind of stuff
going on behind the scenes and have done
like since the 1970s and they own like
loads and loads and loads of different
businesses I was watching One
documentary about them earlier today
that said they own this huge like uh
fishing conglomeration kind of thing and
they said you know how
um Sushi became like really popular in
the United States they're like that's
almost entirely I don't know if this is
true or not but they're like that's
almost entirely because of the
unification church because they like
pushed it into and some of the marriages
that they do they've kind of like forced
you know because they arranged marriages
they kind of like forced um you know
Korean or Japanese members so like marry
Americans so they could like infiltrate
like culturally infiltrate and
religiously infiltrate yeah and [ __ ]
like that that's not how they told the
public what they were doing though well
obviously they don't think he even told
the members that no I remember when all
that was going down they were just
trying to make like uh racial Harmony
they had massive interracial
relationships and massive interracial
marriages in a big like Stadium you know
all simultaneous there's a trip and
there's mostly white people in Koreans
yeah and um this is a Korean religion
um I don't know how big it is in Korean
Korea I didn't see it when I was there
um but it's probably pretty big much
like Scientology I feel like they
inflate their numbers
um they kind of say like on the
Wikipedia page they said oh estimated 3
million but from what I've read they're
like maybe more like 30 000 yeah maybe
there's a lot in Japan which somebody
pointed out and they said that was very
surprising uh Grand there's points out
yeah I'm gonna get into this like
probably toward the end uh they now run
the rod of iron Ministries the AR-15
Church yeah that's the youngest son uh
that's a lot of iron it's some crazy
[ __ ] yeah it's crazy [ __ ] all right
um it's it's not it's not as cool sounds
the uh it's actually kind of terrifying
what's well a lot of people don't
realize is that Korea when you think of
Korea a lot of people would think that
it might be Buddhist that that might be
a Buddhist country or maybe something
kind of like Korean Shinto or something
it's not it's Christian
um it's super crazy super Christian
people don't think that well they're
Affiliated I mean in this country
they're affiliated with a lot of like
super right-wing like religious groups
over here like anti-gay uh anti-semitic
all that kind of stuff they're all in
with that stuff over here it's just the
way the Koreans are
but they you know they they they're in
with all those groups they're very very
homogeneous society I lived there for a
year
very homogeneous
peaceful
but kind of in a way xenophobic you know
um if uh
if a Korean working girl gets knocked up
that baby is not going to be Korean they
uh it ends up in an orphanage and they
send it back to the United States when
it reaches 18. they don't
there is none of this thing where we're
gonna release biracial orphans into the
Korean gene pool they don't do that hmm
now if you were married to her that's a
different story but I don't think they I
don't know if they actually get Korean
citizenship
if you you know they just don't play
that
not there
yeah it's an ethno State like most
countries are they just don't tell you
that but most countries are ethno States
Camp guy said uh Marshall Applewhite in
the heavens Gate cult was pretty weird
yeah we did a show about them not too
long ago I kind of feel like it was
maybe a year or two ago we did a show
about them didn't we Heaven's Gate yeah
I think
yeah we did we did a show on yeah Ben
says what's weird about that there's no
sex or babies on the UFO
what's he talking about Heaven's Gate oh
Heaven's Gate yeah I just said that I
didn't really understand what did you
stop okay I must have missed something
because they were talking about yeah
because you know they all castrated
themselves oh okay no yeah yeah that's
funny it was yeah they were trying to be
genderless they were gender neutral
yeah they weren't imagining be in
general neutral they really were General
gender neutral they cut that [ __ ] off
that's not unusual though
a lot of Cults were like that going all
the way back to ancient Rome they had a
cult that where to enter that cult you
had to you had to chop it off I forgot
what it was called somebody in the
comment section might might be able to
look that up
and um
in the day the days that that one was
around some guys David died during that
process too
but it was like the ultimate virtue
signal uh to chop it off
in that Roman cult
now the average Roman [ __ ] thought
that [ __ ] was ludicrous you know but
well it is yeah but you know that was
totally against everything Romans were
about
they were extremely gendered well I
guess well so that cult was kind of like
very
and what they call it counterculture
they're like oh okay so we're gonna wipe
gender out by doing this
it's kind of I'm look I'm all about
bodily autonomy okay it's just kind of
like hey if you like are into body
modification because I know some people
are and you know like some people get
all like it's like you know they want
their tongue split or they want like you
know to embed horns in their head or get
tattoos all over the body look like
puzzle pieces or something like that
it's like it's your body man like do
whatever you want with it and that goes
up to that up to and includes castration
if you want to castrate yourself then
that is entirely up to you I'm not going
to tell you that you can't do that it's
your dick I wouldn't recommend it
um well I wouldn't recommend it either
but I'm not that person but the thing
about it is that I kind of feel like
I don't know like because I kind of feel
like people that get sucked into these
Cults I'm not sure like how much of
their individuality they still retain
there you go so like I said if you're
just like of like a weirdo freak who's
like you know likes to perform at you
know the gym or a circus or whatever and
you want to do like all this crazy [ __ ]
then then that's you I mean that's you
making that choice you're not in like
some weird group that's like telling you
what to do you know what I mean
yeah I think in in case of these Cults
like in ancient Rome where they were
doing that I think it was uh peer
pressure and just like uh uh you know
called indoctrination and uh Insanity
Mass Insanity you know you get people in
a group and then they start virtue
signaling that [ __ ] can turn into a
goddamn circular firing squad where they
they do bad things to each other just
ask Jim Jones you know that's same thing
same thing you if you can if a cop can
get people to feed poisonous Kool-Aid to
their children they can get you to chop
your [ __ ] dick off well yeah I mean
that's really kind of a lateral move
isn't it but that well that's what I
mean and I kind of feel like even though
the Moonies like the unification Church
they did it well they didn't do anything
exactly like that like that anybody
knows of but they did use many many of
the same like brainwashing type mind
control techniques that other Cults use
including love bombing you know keeping
people awake like uh making people cut
off from their families all the same
kind of [ __ ] that you know Scientology
and like a lot of the other kind of like
uh even more Christian Cults that we've
talked about on the show before like
they did similar kind of [ __ ] to that
yeah they usually do that uh they
justify it by giving it another
explanation you know what I mean they're
not gonna say we're not cutting you off
from your family we're doing something
else you have to go on a spiritual
journey well that's what yeah I was
watching this purifying there was
actually like a really good interview
um I was watching it's on YouTube and I
can't remember what the name of the guy
was but he had actually been born into
the Moonies like his parents were
Rooney's and he and he got the [ __ ] out
like when he was older
but he according to him he said um you
know the phrase love bombing which I
think they kind of use like for a lot of
Cults nowadays but he thought that that
originated with the Moonies which is
possible
and yeah he basically said that's what
they did like they would kind of and
they did that flirty fishing thing too
like they didn't call it that obviously
but it was the same kind of thing Pimpin
for Jesus right and that was just kind
of like he's like yeah they would
approach you know people like the
members of the opposite sex that were
attractive and they would like approach
you and say hey do you want and they
wouldn't bring up religion at first they
would just say hey you want to hang out
or you want to go to this picnic or
whatever and then like very slowly they
would just be like oh you should come on
this weekend retreat with us and it's
like oh let's go on this week-long thing
and then like eventually like once you
were sucked in they'd all be super nice
to you and you know they would just talk
to you like you were the most awesome
person ever and like once they kind of
had their hooks in you like that then
they then they would kind of start like
isolating you from a little bit just
very very slowly so I think that's kind
of how because some people are like well
how can you light let yours let yourself
get sucked into something like that but
I mean I could see it it's I I don't
think it would happen to me because I
don't like hanging out with people in
general anyway and as soon as somebody
said hey want to go no I don't just
leave me alone but you know what I mean
my child children of God is another that
was called what was what was that one
called with the 30 fishing what was the
name of that I think that was children
children of God yeah very fishing wasn't
so much pivot for Jesus it was tricking
for Jesus they were actually to get
donations for the church the girls were
turning themselves out turning tricks
wild [ __ ] man
yeah turning tricks for Jesus then give
the money back to the church yeah and
then they'd try to get members to they
try to get members that way too but they
were they were screwing for donations
and they would would justify it with
using you know religiously and then uh
underage [ __ ] going on adults and
children having sex and using kids is
[ __ ]
you know lures to lure in adults and
just you know they were [ __ ] vile
and like I said even though I don't know
like I was I watched a little bit of an
interview too with like a woman that had
been married to well you know she didn't
choose to marry the guy but like she
they was arranged uh but she married one
of sun uh sunman's Sons yeah and uh she
said that [ __ ] was abusive like
he beat the [ __ ] out of her like when
she was pregnant and like all this other
kind of she was a drug addict and all
this other kind of [ __ ] so grew up in
the royalty of the church they're always
yeah and they yeah they basically said
it was just kind of like any any kind of
cult like this especially the the like
super super like Conservative Christian
ones where they're all like all about
family values you know there's some like
super dysfunctional [ __ ] going on behind
that's not what's going on always well
it's not just the Christians it's all of
them scientology's like that and it's
not Christian
my super dysfunctional well yeah but I'm
just crazy well I'm just saying that
anything that has to do with portraying
like an image of perfection or an image
of like superiority yeah I was like
they're always got way more [ __ ] up
[ __ ] going on than I would ever yeah but
to be honest that's all of them all
cults are like that yeah and they all
portray themselves as being Superior
you joined the cult to achieve a status
different from the rest of society a
superior moral status that's just that's
that's why they're joining a church
they're Commandos for some kind of God
they're an elite Chosen Few that's
that's how they see themselves it
doesn't matter what denomination or what
religion it is they're all like that
yeah Gramps have said I've never
understood how grown-ass smart people
can fall for the man God scam yeah the
thing about it harder they are the
easier it is well I don't
I don't even know I don't think
intelligence is the factor I think it's
personality factors more than
intelligence because people that are
intelligent can still have emotional
issues or they can still have
psychological issues that would make
them more susceptible to that kind of
thing yeah I was in sales I know all
about it it's [ __ ] hard to sell to
somebody who's stupid and has no no
imagination they and a lot of times they
don't have any money
a person who's real smart listens to
reason so you just keep asking them
questions and you Channel them down into
a through a pre-planned uh conversation
to get them to arrive at a conclusion
you want them to arrive to and and they
didn't know that you did that they think
it's their idea and usually this and the
trap is laid to entrap a smart person
not a dumb person
it hits the same thing people aren't as
smart as they think they are
they're just not
John Smith said I think a lot of people
are desperate to hand over
responsibility for their own lives to
others there are some of that too I kind
of feel like and you see this a lot when
we were talking about like Scientology
and stuff like that I kind of feel like
for some people it's really comforting
they want to be part of a community they
want to feel like they're doing
something meaningful with their lives I
think that's an aspect of it but I
definitely do think some people really
feel better when they have a structure
they have somebody else telling them
what to do because it's easier I think a
lot of it has to do with the fact that
smart people
usually come from
basically well-to-do families they don't
have very many Street smarts or defenses
they have a good imagination they can
imagine something better than what they
have and that's what you're going to use
against them you go to a person who's
not very intelligent chances are they're
going to be in the lower work in class
and they're going to be tough all right
and they've they've they've grown up
around people that run game and [ __ ]
lie and cheat and deceive so they don't
they're a very low trust so you can't
bamboozle them
you could tell them something's true and
they wouldn't believe it you know
they're just
it's like trying to reason with a shark
you can't reason with a shark shark just
eats you you know
it's the same deal same thing
Zach says I always worry I'm the kind of
person who could get suckered into a
cult sometimes you don't realize how
quick your life gets away from you well
the thing about it though is I kind of
feel like nowadays I mean I guess it
could still happen but it's harder
because that information is like a lot
more out there and I think more people
are more yeah are more like aware of it
and are aware of all that because pretty
much all of them use the same types of
techniques yeah you know what I'm saying
what you do now if you want to trap
people in the cult you want to use
things like
social media things like Tick Tock and
political and moral arguments you want
to use that you can get them that way
you're not going to be able to get them
with old-fashioned christian-based
religions or any kind of religion that
would it's going to have to be some kind
of political ideology that's how you get
them
and and you could do the same thing to
them with that it's anything you can use
as a tool any kind of philosophy any
kind of belief system can be weaponized
you're telling them what they want to
hear
in exchange they will obey that's what
you do it's that same it's just like
sales it is sales and especially if the
people that write these up and make
these things have an understanding human
psychology
I would imagine that a psychologist
can weaponize their understanding and
invent one of these from scratch that
would travel most people
which would be that's what the CIA was
looking at CIA was deeply involved in
Cults and used Cults as contractors to
do things
so yeah
yeah I mean but like I said it sounds
crazy but no mostly no it's not crazy I
mean uh even down at Argentina you know
the perons used those weird ass Germans
that were trying to keep children from
turn having puberty remember that that
pedophile was running it they were using
that as uh some kind of torture base
what was the name of that I thought we
did a show on them no I don't think down
in Argentina
we were thinking about doing a show
about that but I don't and I think I put
it in the poll a couple times but it
never once so I don't think we got
around to it down in Argentina unless I
totally forgot about it which is
possible it wasn't it wasn't dignity
Community it was another it was another
one
he was a German guy some of the people
that were in there were kind of like
runaway Nazis
but they were in a totally enclosed
community that sold sausages and Made
bread and they had a pretty good uh uh a
pretty good relation with the outside
world and
the guy who ran it was like it was like
a Christian cult I remember which
probably Lutheran or something something
German
and um he was a pedo
and um
he was trying to use medical Tech
Medical understanding to keep children
from going through puberty thereby they
wouldn't they would bypass the original
they would stay hot so they would stand
up that's really to put in for
disgusting to us but he he explained it
to the followers that it was that way
they could sidestep the original sin
that God would see them as children
instead of adult it sounds [ __ ] oh Mr
loophole yeah all right well the
um
the intelligence organizations of
Argentina found out about this and they
didn't bust them up they used them
that's some wild [ __ ] they used them as
subcontractors and they were
doing torture
stuff there and imprisoning people and
those Germans were helping them
Argentine Germans
Tammy says what all you Irregulars in
the chat are forgetting is that you are
in a cult The Cult of Pookie
you know Pookie so I can run around and
pookalating this whole [ __ ] place
she's running around here throwing [ __ ]
and trying to distract me well yeah
because as soon as she knows where
they're going to do the show she's like
I want to come in I want to come in
because she was just sleeping out in her
cat tree but as soon as she was her
little eyes popped open she doesn't then
she jumped down she doesn't know what a
show is she just thinks that we're
talking at these lights yeah and she's
like and hey I'm running around back
here and rolling over and being cute and
you guys aren't looking at me what the
[ __ ] yeah why are you talking these
lights
why are you talking to somebody other
than poking yeah who are you talking to
foreign
she doesn't know but probably every time
we say her name she's like you're
talking about me because she knows what
her name is yeah
she wouldn't I mean you
Pookie doesn't mind she's just she's
she's the head of her own cult but she
wouldn't abuse it she's not that kind of
kitty
I don't think I don't think she's that
kind of kitty I wouldn't know all hail
the overhead fan
oh
Mark says I've heard humans have a
symbolic life that's usually filled by
religion philosophy art music Etc maybe
this cult [ __ ] is like a twisted version
of the symbolic life I guess it kind of
could be because
I don't know I have met people that were
really into I don't know like it's it's
hard for me to say because you know I
was not raised religiously and I didn't
really grow up around that so it's like
it all seems weird to me but I've I've
met people before that it seemed like
that was all they were interested in
like they just that's all they talked
about was their Church stuff and they
were like which fine okay that's like
what they were into but I don't know it
just came across this really weird to me
because I didn't grow up like that you
know I mean they're they're talking
about politics and the politics of Cults
and Q Anon and all that [ __ ] well
yeah I would think so to a certain
extent but uh don't feel all Superior
because everything in a way is a cult
including corporations the corporations
also are kind of set up as a cult the US
Army was a cult all right the airborne
troops the uh Rangers and special forces
were Warrior Cults inside of another
cult okay everything is a cult
the guy so if everything is a cult then
nothing is nothing that has a very
historic definition it is true okay and
we're talking about a religion there's
culture that has a difference there's a
difference between
adherence of like a religion and
adherence of a cult there is a market
difference I think it's just I think it
has to do with the the degree of it well
that's I'm not saying that it's not that
I'm just saying there's a market degree
I'm not saying it's a long it's not
along the same Spectrum yeah it's the
same thing it's just very extreme it's
just an extreme
um even the goth scene is kind of a has
cult-like qualities to it all right but
there's a difference between a religious
cult and a cult
do you know what I mean
and uh some of these some of these
religious cults can get pretty uh but
then you look at [ __ ] that was happening
in the Deep South going back forever the
way the churches were organized
you know they're they're not Central
there's no central control in say like
uh a Southern Baptist Church is in the
South they were just kind of
do-it-yourself things that would pop up
that's what I mean it's like now the
thing is it's like can you just come and
go and leave and like nobody gets all up
your ass about it or you know anything
like that it's like the the definition
of a cult is they're trying to like suck
you and like pretty much take you out of
reality and put you in their reality
they're trying to isolate you from the
outside world essentially so that that
so that they are the only source of
information that you're getting yeah
that's a lot okay well then that that is
common practice that is a common
practice with a lot of organ
corporations will do that yeah but
corporations still let you go home at
night and you can consume other sources
of information you're not it's it's not
just coming from the corporation you
know what I mean like where you work for
example like I know some corporations
like Walmart uh are more cult-like than
others but you know because I've known
some people that work there but um you
know so so it's kind of like that but
like I said they're not keeping you from
going home they're not like locking you
up at night and like making you stay
there and like and it's like you can
only listen to like Walmart propaganda
and [ __ ] like that it's not like
Scientology where they're like you're
not allowed to like go on
non-scientology websites and you're not
allowed to like read regular newspapers
and you're not allowed you know what I
mean you're it's like that they're
trying to like cut off all of your
outside sources of information it's in
that same realm it's just like we were
saying earlier it's it's the differences
in the degrees Yeah and the reasons yeah
that's that yeah that's not that's not
uh I don't think anyone's arguing with
that right because what you're talking
about cut yourself off from the outside
world not taking things hey you're
talking about the Army Rangers now all
of a sudden
you know that's the way it is in boot
camp and it's like that in [ __ ]
Ranger School uh any any kind of [ __ ]
Elite
fighting unit it has high security
around it that you really they don't
really want you gone you know I mean
you're on duty that's you can't go home
you know your home is there at the Fort
or wherever it is you're stationed and
that's all on purpose
they don't want you to know all that
much about what's going on and they
don't want intelligence agencies to know
anything about you
and you're not supposed to have social
media and things you know it's going to
be for security reasons but it's kind of
two-way to Shield you from outside
information and then to Shield the world
from you so it's two different things
happening at the same time and also
because you know they don't want other
they don't want foreigners to know about
you because if they know where you are
they know where your unit is
you know
and they don't want the they don't want
foreigners or enemy intelligence agents
to know where the unit is deployed
you know so it's there's a lot of that
that kind of crosses over into the realm
of cult
I lived it
right but I mean it's not like a
religious cult which is what we're
talking about though
there was kind of I mean there's aspects
people like I said there's aspects there
are a lot of there's a ritual concepts
of what happens after you die Concepts
involving life and death uh dying with
your friends there's a element of
suicide pact sometime in it
certain elements you know what I mean
like well we we're gonna die we're all
going to die there's a unit you know
that kind of [ __ ]
um because it's easier to die in a group
than it is
you don't want to do that [ __ ] alone you
know so no it's close it's real close
there were Viking Warrior Cults that you
know they were probably just like that
um
yeah
you can kinda
put religious myths in your own mind
around pretty much everything even if
it's not a religion
you know
grandpa said being a federal agent was
kind of like being a cult except we were
always complaining about the [ __ ] they
made us do which is very Uncle like yeah
right
um John Smith said I would I'm glad I
was not raised with religion uh thank my
mother's Albanian State atheism yeah I
was really glad I wasn't raised
religious too I would have sucked um I
do remember believing with all my heart
in Santa Claus Jesus Preposterous Santa
tell me more well yeah I mean because
Santa brings you toys what the [ __ ] does
Jesus do nothing I was raised around it
but it wasn't it wasn't a big factor you
know I mean it wasn't fundamentalist it
was just vague yeah yeah God yeah Jesus
okay yeah yeah yeah yeah all right Jesus
yeah he wasn't all right guy yeah yeah
yeah don't do bad [ __ ] yeah don't do
anything bad
yeah you died Jesus is there which like
I said that's fine you know it's like
I'm I'm not religious personally but um
you know if that's kind of the extent of
it but once you get into this thing
where everything's like super hardcore
and you're trying to like infest other
people's lives with your weird ass
beliefs too yeah but I thought Jesus was
a historical figure that had existed in
the past some kind of preacher in Rome
and they built a religion around him I
thought that's what it was
uh but Jenny watch me listen to the
material
Scholars talk you know Dr Robert Price
we had him on the show
going through Christ's myth Theory
and and Jenny saw me [ __ ] get
convinced of going oh no okay yeah that
guy couldn't have existed because I told
you I read about that like a long time
ago and I was like yeah and I was like
yeah that sounds reasonable that he
wasn't really a real person and I was
just like okay fine the more you find
out about the way it's written yeah what
we have and what what
if there was
a historical person
named Jesus that a religion was based on
nothing of him exists anymore nothing in
that Bible is from that guy
so therefore
if you're a Christian you're believing
stuff that was written about a guy and
what was written had nothing to do with
the real guys so the Jesus you believe
in never was never never really existed
you're believing a myth that was based
on a person but well well it's a myth
based on older myths because everything
about Jesus actually came from older
myths yeah it was borrowed it's and it's
all from Mostly from Roman stuff yeah
and um
I'm really into mythology it's like you
know everything he supposedly said kind
of came from Roman stuff and Socrates
and other wise men and it gets the point
to where you know you don't even really
need this to be based on some old
preacher in Rome it probably wasn't and
then you go find out you go no there's
an angel named Jesus that's probably
what they're talking about and the angel
of Jesus is even set mentioned in the
Pauline material
so it's just very strange to me that
that people get butt hurt when you say
that well it probably wasn't a real
person I'm like look that doesn't mean
that you can't still
you know uh be like read the teachings
and take what you want from it it's like
it doesn't diminish it if that's what
you want to believe just because it
wasn't a real guy
it's exactly the same as Hercules or
Apollo or the same yeah like I said so
you know and and myths they came about
to teach people things like teach more
because people remember stories better
than they do just like you know rules
and [ __ ]
so it was the same kind of thing and
like I said there's nothing wrong with
that that's just what humans are like
that's how we teach things to people and
I was like well you know they crucified
this guy so he must have been telling
the truth but then you find out the
crucifixion As Told in those Gospels
just a reenactment of the Jewish
scapegoat ritual of releasing the evil
put putting putting the tribe's sins on
the scale like symbolically yeah send it
away that's that's Letting Go Barabbas
and then you're sacrificing the pure
lamb and you're using the blood to wash
Away The Sins of your of the of the of
the Jewish tribe
that's [ __ ] the crucifixion that's
what they're talking about they're even
doing it on a Passover or no they don't
pass over they're doing it on that day I
think
they were doing it on a day that I don't
remember which one it was Dr Price was
on they have to go back and look at it I
don't think it was Passover
they're doing it on the same day that
you're supposed to do that ritual so
it's all [ __ ] that's what they're
talking about the blood of the Lamb
washing away the tribe's sins that the
Christians say that they just don't
realize what that means
Jewish Purity Magic
adopted by Romans the enemy like [ __ ]
like that is fascinating to me all that
kind of like where I I'm fascinated by
where myths come from like what the
origins of them were
and it's like it's way more interesting
than actually believing that the myths
are real that's for sure if there was a
guy named Jesus
he's not into those gospels they're not
talking about him anymore
be like Sam oh there was a Superman of
course there was a Superman we know
there wasn't a metropolis but we know
they're talking about New York there had
to been a Superman it was yeah
yeah it was based on a Jewish kid that
you know his family sent him to America
to 2 000 years from now they're gonna
have that yeah they're gonna have that
exact discussion yeah but that Jewish
kid that ran from the Nazis is not
Superman he wrote the story
it's a big difference he couldn't fly he
he wasn't he he didn't get nothing we
know of he couldn't he didn't comple at
the side of Krypton or Kryptonite you
know what I mean even like deflect
bullets or anything you know
yeah sure so let's get into the Moonies
well wait Hugo says so I found this this
is actually really good where'd you find
this at because this is very this is a
very good succinct uh summation a
religion belongs to the wider culture
its adherents come and go freely see
that's what I said occult tends to be
counter-cultural restricting the social
life of its adherence to other cult
members like I said that's one of the
first things they do is they try to
isolate you from outside influences your
friends and your family and make sure
that you associate only with other
people that believe the same thing as
you do so that's one of the things that
characterizes a cult not the only thing
but yeah that's kind of how you know
you're getting sucked into it if they're
just kind of like taking over your life
and like I said the Moonies did that too
they did that whole love bombing thing
but you know who else does that
those companies that sell magazine
subscriptions kind of did that Kirby
vacuum cleaner kind of did that kind of
[ __ ] they were it's kind of like Jordan
the circus with those guys but it was
kind of cult-like also
um although like I said subscription it
would be different if they if you went
to work like uh you know and they
wouldn't let you go home and they're
like you can only like associate with
your co-workers you can't see your
parents or your friends or your spouse
they always use subterfuge when you
joined the damn
the subscriptions selling not saying
some companies wouldn't like to do that
because they absolutely would when you
join the subscription people first of
all you were probably semi-homeless when
you joined and young and then they put
you on tour so you were constantly
touring around the country in a damn
little bus so that's how they kept you
away from your family and other people
because you were on tour
you know kind of like a traveling hippie
cope kind of let me just drop you off
and you go out there and sell some
magazines prescriptions they'd be out
there for [ __ ] months at a time
um the Moonies also did that kind of
stuff you know how
um they would do you know how sometimes
like when and they still do it nowadays
I don't know if it's Moonies but you
have people like going around selling
like in a club and uh selling roses and
[ __ ] yeah like they did that kind of
stuff
they'd go around on the street like
selling roses and whatnot that was like
they raised money like that
um
Jasper says Christianity what happens
when a girl just sticks to her story no
matter what
somebody mentioned it see what happens
see what happens they're talking about
how problematic the crucifixion is the
crucifixion narrative in terms of like
Roman law oh yeah they did the Romans
wouldn't have cared and uh and then the
whole thing about you know the the
Jewish population rising up and calling
for the death of this uh preacher you
know during the time of pilate no no it
just wouldn't happen I don't think it
would happen
and then Pontius pilot just kind of
showed as the good guy because he's
roaming but they haven't said that
Pontius Pilate was [ __ ] was hated in
Judea and was pretty pretty much a bad
dude
um
had a dude like Jesus come before me
just would have killed him without any
he was kind of like Saddam Hussein he
was like that you know this would have
killed him without any question but the
the Romans are always shown in a
positive light in the in the uh in the
gospels pretty much
um
you know so that it says so they're
telling you right there that it's a
Roman religion
you know Jesus is saying oh see my own
people don't believe me but these Romans
they understand it you know the Romans
are cool the Romans
they have faith yeah
you know some Roman was like yeah it
feels like something that's right well
there's one little one little narrative
where like a some kind of Roman
Centurion as as Jesus can you really
heal my son he's sick and he's like uh
he goes yeah I can heal him and he goes
look and and he could he goes okay with
the healing then and and uh Jesus says
okay he's healed he goes okay thank you
and Jesus is like you don't want to
check and he's like no no if you say
he's healed he's healed and Jesus turns
to see they have faith
you know he's like you're right yeah
y'all y'all y'all Jewish people you
don't have faith in me that'd be like if
you pay somebody and they're gonna stand
there and count the money in front of
you right
they don't it's a narrative it's a
religion the whole thing's a religious
narrative and it's yeah you you'd think
that
it sounds kind of crazy if you're not
Christian if you didn't grow up with it
if you grew up with it it sounds oh yeah
that's the real thing but those Mormons
oh no what they believe is [ __ ] crazy
but if you're neither Mormon nor
Christian they're equally crazy see like
like I said to me they all sound equally
crazy yeah like because you know what I
mean so like no offense but I'm just
saying that because I didn't grow up
religious like I knew religious people
but not many like I never went to church
as a child I had some relatives that
went but like I never went and so to me
it just all seemed equally ridiculous I
was I didn't see even from a young age I
didn't see a difference between I
because it occurred to me when I was you
know 10 11 years old I was like had I
been born in another country I would
believe they're yeah you know whatever
[ __ ] they believe just as
stringently as people over here like
believe whatever [ __ ] they believe
that they're born into so I was like so
that must mean that they're all [ __ ]
that was that was the conclusion that I
came to
I always liked him I always liked
religion I'm
I'm interested in them I just there's
being interested in the mythology
because like I said I love mythology I
love I love I even love urban legends I
love all that kind of like ancient
mythology anything like that I'm
fascinated by stories and like the
stories that people come up with to
explain the world around them when they
don't understand it like that to me is
like really really interesting but
there's a whole world of difference
between being interested in that and
like believing this [ __ ] is literally
true even as a kid I didn't care whether
it was really where it was literally
true or not I didn't really think of it
that way I thought of it in
like man that's a cool ass movie that's
a cool story yeah cool story bro that's
how I thought about it basically I like
you know like mostly Old Testament
stories I I like those you know
you know um
somebody would say well yeah did that
really happen
by the time I think I'd gotten around
probably about the sixth grade I
probably said no that didn't happen
but it doesn't matter you know what I
mean that's you know I still like the
story
yeah it's still a good and actually
um I read something somewhere a long
time ago that said you know it's like
these are just good stories it's like
just sitting there and insisting that
they're true I think he was talking
specifically about
um like the Noah's Ark story or yeah
things or the creationist kind of
narrative he's like you know you're
taking a perfectly beautiful story and
like trying to cram it into reality
you're ruining it you're ruining it
you're ruining the story it's a great
story it's not with mythology and these
stories were for right that's what
that's what he was that's what he was
they were supposed to ground you within
a certain cultural belief system and to
give you certain uh of value systems and
to explain where things came from in a
novel way
um there's truth in these stories
they're not true though in the same way
there's a lot of Truth in Star Wars in
good Star Wars they're not true though
Star Wars didn't happen well yeah I mean
well the thing about it yeah you can
watch a movie yeah a movie that was made
by human beings it's like there's real
emotions in there and things you can
relate to and stories you can possibly
relate to that doesn't mean that what
happened in that movie actually happened
yeah but that doesn't make it any less
that you can like relate to it because
you can like you know you have empathy
you can like portray yourself as that
person you can relate to that person and
it can maybe help you deal with some
some [ __ ] neural whole own life I think
that's kind of like the whole point of
stories what's funny about religions
is that religions always come from
heresy
they tend to kind of spring up out of
nowhere fully formed and new but they're
based upon something that people used to
believe or believed at one time so
they're reboots
and a reboot would be a heresy from the
point of view of the old religion
so
the chances of there being any
historical figures in any of these is
very slim very slim
um now
in the Mormon or you know Church of
Latter-day Saints there are real there
really was a Joseph Smith and all these
guys yeah I mean that was they really
were there we know that because there
were photographs of them and uh they
know where they're lived but he's making
this he's making a new religion all
right and he's doing it in a modern era
I don't think you could do that anymore
he did it he was probably one of the
last guys that could probably do it and
make a religion
and he didn't make it from scratch
either yeah he sold a bunch of stuff
yeah well nobody does because nobody
does you take stuff that worked in other
contexts like with other religions and
they just kind of Cobble it together you
have to take things that people already
believed right uh because so it was
Christianity and spiritualism mixed
together with some Masonic stuff because
people believed in it and there it is
you make it Grandpa said someone once
gave me a movie with Kirk Cameron called
Fireproof
you watched it oh my God how about
having a Christian marriage two hours
forever lost yeah um I never sat through
the whole entire movie but um I have
watched a couple of like jokey like
atheist breakdowns of it and that movie
looks
insufferable it doesn't look quite as
insufferable as the Kirk Cameron like uh
Christian Christmas movie which is
called saving Christmas which I actually
sort of want to watch
but I don't know if I'm quite that
masochistic maybe I'll get around to it
one day it'd be great if like [ __ ]
riff tracks would do it but I don't
think they would because that would
probably be too controversial a choice
to do like Maybe not maybe they'll get
maybe they've done it I don't know but
oh Kurt Cameron poor [ __ ]
starting this yeah fireproof he did one
called was he there was another one
because he was in a bunch of them
I think there was one called war room
two that he was in but I think fireproof
is kind of like the most
uh notorious one I guess because of how
bad it is he had a porn addiction that's
right didn't he have a porn addiction in
that one yeah that was the porn
addiction movie
like that's the kind that's literally
like the only [ __ ] problem that's
your dad
Alex
he had like a nice house a nice family a
nice kid and everything oh he just looks
at porn a little bit too much that it
had to be this big [ __ ] angsty
[ __ ]
Jasper said saving Christmas is my
number one Christmas viewing may like I
said I've seen clips of it and I've seen
like you know funny like breakdowns of
it and it's like I almost kind of want
to watch it but then I kind of don't
because I'll probably just want to like
scream and hit the screen you know
somebody asking if Star Wars is heresy
what is this
wait uh where where
hold on I saw it but I didn't John Smith
oh so Star Wars reboot is heresy yeah
yeah yeah definitely new Star Wars is
heresy [ __ ] right it is granther says
his Port Addiction in the movie was
looking at swimsuit models super lame
addiction yeah I mean if you're gonna go
the addiction route at least [ __ ]
at least [ __ ] commit I mean if you're
gonna have a porn addiction get some
[ __ ] dirty ass porn up in there come
on
swimsuit models it's like oh he's
looking at the Sears catalog
that was that was something that's like
all they could show that was all they
could show that's like so [ __ ] funny
that's like I don't know why I just
thought of this but I remembered that
like Ed Wood movie from the 50s where
it's like they they rated like a
pornography studio and they the cops
literally like come in there and the
dude is taking a picture of like two
girls in bathing suits like one piece
bathing suits not even bikinis and I'm
like what
and like that I think it was and it was
on MST so like Crow says wow if they if
they snag these people think of all the
arrests they could make at the beach you
know what I mean because it's like they
were just wearing [ __ ] bathing suits
ridiculous ridiculous
uh let's see
[Music]
um
Ben says I wish I could post memes here
I have one with Jesus saying are you
addicted to masturbation join me and we
can beat it together
one of my favorite Jesus memes and I
just remembered it because Facebook
reminded me because I posted it like
several years ago it was that um it's
kind of like a famous painting of like
Jesus being like Ascend into heaven or
something like that and all the people
going oh he's ascending to heaven and
then he's then he says something at the
bottom like it's like help me you idiots
the aliens are taking it but it's like
it made me laugh so hard like the first
[ __ ] time I saw that but yeah so uh
all right hey Dave what's up hello
YouTube just got out of work yeah it's
Wednesday so
is it karaoke night I think it's karaoke
night tonight do they still do karaoke
at mannequins on Wednesday yeah I think
they do well I think it's a popular
night now actually from So based on some
of the videos we've been through it one
time but it was a while back and they
had like six people and there was like
nobody there yeah
and I was and I was too I wasn't drunk
enough to participate yeah I'd have to
be like really drunk and I'm really
drunk to do that
um let's see where to do
all right
okay so I was like making sure that we
had anything so you want to talk about
the monies oh before we do that
um we got yeah that's right a new
Patron okay named Cami okay so welcome
Cami also Tammy who I think is here
um she returned
to patreon okay thank you and came back
so thank you very much Tammy and Tammy
we need new patrons a patronage for
slipped we used to do like 600 bucks a
month on patreon which really helped out
we're now down to like 300. it took
several years less than that even
because less than that I think it's like
250. 250. yeah it took three couple
years for it to slide down that that low
some people you know they got new ATM
cards and they get kicked back so that
could happen uh so people just leave
over time you know [ __ ] hard times
hit them but um we're always looking for
new patrons and uh Jenny could really
[ __ ] help uh use your help another
thing that we did is that we um got some
Blu-rays did we announce the new
Blu-rays that we got yeah that's what
another thing I was gonna do and Louie
who I don't think is here we said this
on yesterday's show or Monday show I
can't remember but Louie who is uh here
all the time and always sends us really
Kick-Ass movies yeah good movies to
refer sent us a couple of movies to
review he sent us some he sent us Pulp
Fiction yep there you go 4K Ultra HD yep
and he also sent us Reservoir Dogs which
uh we just reviewed yesterday so I don't
have it here with me and look he also
sent us like a 50 gift card thank you
very much
so thank you very much for Christmas
thank you very much that is really
really awesome every little bit helps
for the show
but yeah
but yeah but uh no we're looking for uh
new patrons and uh you guys are our uh
[ __ ] hardcore you guys in the in the
chat are hardcore fans and there's a lot
of you you know um if if all of you were
to just actually just shipping five
bucks a month it would make a big
difference
and I try thank you Jeff ER thank you oh
thanks man what do you say just finished
grading my students for the fall
semester Oy Vey the less said the better
I'm kind of that bad huh
um also I'll be traveling on Friday for
the holidays and I just want to wish you
guys good tidings and the best new year
thank you very much you have a really
really good holiday I can't believe
[ __ ] Christmas is like it's not well
it's not next week well it kind of is
next week isn't it I think it's two
weeks from now
what's up what the [ __ ] today it's
14th right yeah [ __ ] it is next week
yeah okay
oh my God how did this happen it seemed
like it was just Halloween VA I thought
was gonna send me a letter about when my
next appointment was and I thought it
was supposed to be this week and they
never got anything from yeah I thought
you were supposed to because you told me
you were supposed to because I know they
rescheduled you from because you had
that I think it might have been Friday
huh
I think it was supposed to be Friday
but they said they would send me the
confirmation letter did you even check
the mail today yeah
we didn't get any Melody
that's unusual
unless it came late
it doesn't usually yeah Danny rolling
said yeah moderator uh Tila and Sandra
are more than likely dead or locked up
yeah I don't know yeah where the [ __ ]
are those two I don't know I don't know
maybe we set them to make them they've
been gone for a long time yeah I haven't
seen Taylor or Sandra in a really long
time I mean I like I said I'm pretty
sure Tila moved so I don't know but I
don't even think she's like commented on
any of our stuff like either not that I
remember she was moving out of San
Francisco
hopefully she's all right yeah and I
hope Sandra's all right
in Germany yeah she's gonna be freezing
her ass off man the energy Bill's gonna
be Sky High this way this year
but that's I mean the thing about I was
always surprised she was here because
Germany is like wait what would they be
like six hours later I don't know even
Sarah came back home
remember Sarah
oh she got a German boyfriend who that
girl yeah Sarah with a c oh yeah she's
back
great she's looking for you
she's not
Sarah was one of Jenny's greatest Rivals
back in the day gosh what a horrible I
don't hate a lot well no that's not true
I was gonna say Sarah got the man I
don't hate a lot of people but Sarah got
them I mean Jimmy got the man so yeah I
was gonna say it was Sarah didn't get it
Sarah was pissed that Jenny got the man
but uh I'd be on a date with Jenny man
she wanted to jump on your dick so hard
back in the old days yeah [ __ ] I'd be
I'd be in the car running around with
[ __ ] Jenny and [ __ ] she called me
on my phone and be [ __ ] screaming at
me over the [ __ ] cell phone that I
was with you she's a lunatic she's a
lunatic yeah and I she said well she was
my girlfriend yeah she was my girl well
that's what I mean like one night we
were coming home like poor Kaylee she
was in the backseat of the car that
night we were coming over for the club
and she called you in the club we were
going through McDonald's drive there and
she said yeah she said she was gonna
come to your house yeah she's gonna come
to my house and everything and I was
staying at your house yep
I was like man if that [ __ ] is in the
bushes I'm gonna knock her out and she
wasn't my girlfriend
I mean I went on I didn't really go on a
date with her
yeah didn't you I even hit then you go
out like one time yeah I didn't have sex
with her yeah you know I don't know
where she got that she was she was a
crazy person
and then she sicked her sister on me she
was legit her sister was crazy too
remember that yeah I remember how could
I forget we were in the club man all
right did you see where [ __ ] lunatics
yeah I don't know what their [ __ ]
problem was man
God damn how long ago was that now about
10 years at least at least 10 yeah yeah
I think it was like 10 years anyway she
moved off to Germany to be with some
dude
she came back now now she's back she's
looking for Jenny
[Laughter]
looking for you bro it's you looking for
you probably not no honestly I see her
it's like I think she was at ibar one
time like not a couple years back that
was the last time I see her and I just
like looked at her and I just rolled my
eyes like huh they used to push he tried
she used to try to push Jenny off a
stage yeah if they're on the stage on
the little boxes till it till I grabbed
her and like they ripped their footman
put my [ __ ] handwriters for it like
that and squeezed
she didn't do that again
that was some weird [ __ ] man it was like
a [ __ ] it's like hey don't don't play
I'll put up with a lot but you pushed me
past a certain Breaking Point yeah but
knock your ass out
don't play that
Jenny threw her ass off the [ __ ]
stage I didn't throw her off the stage
that's a lie you pushed her off I didn't
push her off she didn't fall off the the
I just pushed her against the the
railing oh okay yeah that's right and I
just put my and I just partially
strangled her that's right you put your
foot you grabbed it by the throat and
she reported me to uh the bartender Lee
who was our friend and Lee told her to
get them and Lee told her to get the
[ __ ] out because we couldn't stand her
either he didn't like her either yeah uh
thank you Zach some folding money for
repair for a pair I really appreciate
thank you you guys are awesome thank you
very much you guys are awesome you guys
are awesome
Ben says the hot crazy index in action
yeah she's kind of hot
um yeah she's yeah she's actually a
beautiful girl yeah but uh she's just
crazy
tall skinny
not my type really
I like I don't know what she looks like
now I haven't seen her she looks same
exactly she looks exactly exactly the
same uh she I kind of like short and
voluptuous boobs you know boobs
hourglass you know I like hourglass he
likes boobs with a head boobs with a
head and footings
booty big legs
little ways doesn't really matter which
face looks like
um I mean it does yeah I'm just teasing
yeah it does not just teasing you and
then you know but that's physically what
I like I like variety though too you
know just but that's like my main one
that's his main one I like him like it
Jenny actually fit that bill
she didn't fit the bill yeah
that's about it Ben says head optional
I'm gonna get one of those weird sex
toys that's just like I sold a couple of
those when I had an Amazon sex toy store
that was just like a vaginal air well I
don't know if it wasn't just a vaginal
area it was just like a lower torso yeah
let's call it that yeah
with like a like a vagina hole in a
booty hole and I'm like
I'm like I get why they make that but
it's like wouldn't it be kind of weird I
don't know I think that's like some
weird serial killer [ __ ] so like shading
over into that no no no judgment like if
somebody has one of those but
a lot of my buddies are black they tend
to be ex-military black guys and uh this
has nothing to do with it but I tend to
kind of like the same kind of I like to
say white girls black guys like
so the cut the full figure you know not
fat just that
what they call thick today I like thick
you know
yeah see I like yeah when I was a
teenager the only like no white boys
liked me
dick it was it was all like yeah the
black guys were running down yeah
Hispanic guys and Hispanics yeah well
they know it's good yeah and yeah the
the white dudes are kind of behind
behind the curve back in the day they
like they like a little [ __ ] skinny
girl cook cookware with big [ __ ]
implants you know they basically they
were in they were into the kind of like
the Sonia figure yeah although Sonja she
looked good with clothes but you know
[ __ ] she just didn't have a booty
you know and or legs she was just like I
mean she had legs but just like a stick
figure with boobs that would be weird if
she didn't have legs at all it was just
a little stick figure yeah she was very
very thin yeah well she didn't eat that
look looks real good in clothing
yeah yeah it's why you see it in like a
fashion model type stuff well because
and we've talked about this before I
know we're getting like very far afield
yeah we're getting from the topic but I
was gonna say um tall skinny women look
good in pretty much everything right
it's so you know if you have a different
body type than that it's much harder to
look good and close but
if you're thick you better [ __ ] be
wearing [ __ ] the skin tight that [ __ ]
accentuates kind of an hourglass figure
if you don't have an hourglass figure
try to get one
yeah
and implants helps too because you need
internal support for everything just
look on Instagram you can see what what
they're working with they got if a woman
carry his weight well it looks good it
looks real good
Ben says Reverend moon like tall skinny
women with glasses probably probably
maybe so either I don't know if that's
true or if he's just trying to get us
back on the topic because we haven't
even [ __ ] started and we're already
inside Koreans like skinny people we've
only been well it's not like you see
that many fat Koreans I mean maybe
nowadays you do I feel like people are
getting fatter all over the place they
thought man when I was when they adopted
the American diet when I was living when
I was living in Korea
all the club girls right
they they gave the white boys all the
second rate the second and third rate
[ __ ] club girls all right that's what
they consider to be second third rate
and to us they looked fine they were
[ __ ]
a lot of them were thick they had curves
and [ __ ] and then they're like we'll
give the Americans whoa wow boom you
know but but in the Korean culture at
that time in the early 90s that was
considered to be a fat girl
isn't that something
yeah well I would consider it'd be like
a fat girl but we you know it's like
hell and hell no you know it's hilarious
I was watching like um I guess it's like
a Japanese horror movie the other day
and one of the characters they were all
like teenagers and one of the characters
was like
they called her like the fat girl and
like the joke was that she just like ate
all the time and she was always eating
but she was like seriously like Infamous
infinitesimally like larger than the
other ones and I was like that's what
they call a fat girl or they're holy
[ __ ]
because she was like um
not fat by any stretch of the
imagination
remember Tori
yeah princess Indian princess Tori when
when Tori was real um
her build that's the kind of Korean
build that they were throwing at us yeah
and she was fine man you know but it's
just kind of that
that that's the look but that they were
rejecting that build yeah I don't
understand that well that's just like
not what they grew up with and I guess
yeah it's like culturally it was
cultural yeah well it was just like here
back in the 70s and [ __ ] like that if
you didn't look like a skinny Coke or
yeah and everyone thought you were just
like a [ __ ] terrible heart you know
what I mean yeah it was that kind of
thing too
so it goes both ways we did it as well
uh all right so after all of that yeah
now that now that I'm like I'll make
another drink in a bit all right so
we're talking about the Moonies yeah
it's always kind of fun talking about
cults because I'm fascinated by Cults in
general just how people like I said how
people get sucked into them [ __ ] like
that I like to think it couldn't happen
to me but you know what I mean it
happened to anybody I guess but
I'm not a joiner so I guess that's kind
of like a big thing I can't come to
anybody it happens to people though
it could happen to me
well like I said I kind of feel like it
wouldn't happen to me because I'm not a
joiner like the second that somebody is
like hey join my group I'm like no
no I know how they work so I know what
it is well I know how they work too but
and I was around scientologists and like
immediately I was like you guys are all
[ __ ] weirdos and I don't want to like
hang out with any of you ever but I'm
not like I said I'm not a joiner I'm
more of like a lone loner person I don't
I don't really like being in big groups
it weirds me out so I so I don't know if
I'd ever really like want to get
involved in anything like that so
obviously unification Church which is
kind of what it's supposed to I guess
nowadays like Moonies is considered like
a little bit derogatory but
normally I wouldn't be like an [ __ ]
and just like call people a derogatory
name just like to be an [ __ ] but I
don't know it's a cult so I'm not really
that worried about it
so this was actually founded by
obviously the Reverend son myungmoon
back in 1954 in Seoul Korea
so again this is a very Christian cult
and some of the stuff that they believe
is not
it's a little bit removed from maybe
kind of like traditional Christian stuff
but not really that removed like when I
get into it it's not really like all
that weird
so even though it started out in South
Korea and I kind of feel like that's
probably where most of its adherents are
nowadays as well as Japan they have a
lot of uh adherence there as well
but they apparently have uh you know
followers everywhere although as I said
not as many as they
pause it I kind of feel like much like
Scientology which this kept reminding me
of for some reason uh you know their
Wikipedia page like I said they said oh
we have three million members around the
world which possible I'm sure that's
possible but
I don't really know I I don't really
know if if there's really that many
uh like I said the numbers I saw were
more like
maybe in the U.S like 10 000 maybe I
don't know
so it started out like the name it
started out as was actually the Holy
Spirit Association for the unification
of world Christianity which you know
that's a mouthful
um but in 1994 he actually changed the
name of it to the family Federation for
world peace and unification his kind of
whole thing was he thought that
he basically wanted to unite everybody
under one religion which
I you know I could tell you right from
this jump that's not going to work out
but okay
but that anytime anybody has an idea
like that I'm just kind of like the
that's not gonna happen
so uh so like I said largest number in
South Korea and Japan
now as I mentioned earlier which Tom
amazingly did not know but this church
has a [ __ ] ton of front groups uh and
they have all kind of stuff and a lot of
the front groups like a lot of them are
kind of like political action committees
and [ __ ] like that but they also have
like a bunch of other businesses that
don't on their face have anything to do
with religion so you got to be really
careful and there's actually I think
there's a list like Wikipedia has its
own page of like all the
all of the groups that they that are
front groups for them so like check that
out like whenever you're getting because
I was like it's too many to like list on
here because it was like a million and I
was like oh my God that'd be like really
boring if I just sat there and listed
all that but go and check because
there's like a [ __ ] ton there's a [ __ ]
ton and some of it is like
like I said some of it doesn't have
anything to do with religion some of it
is just kind of like oh they have like
this uh you know they own like an online
encyclopedia or they own like a ballet
company or [ __ ] like that it's like
weird [ __ ] like that they're sneaky like
that like I said they're very much like
Scientology scientologists like that too
so basically they're kind of referred to
as the unification movement
so the beliefs of this cult I'm just
going to call them a cult I know we're
supposed to call it like a new religious
movement or a sect or whatever but it's
a cult so I'm that's what I'm gonna call
it
so the beliefs basically comes from this
textbook which was written by Moon
himself which is called the Divine
principle because of course it is
now the beliefs kind of laid out in this
book they believe in a universal God
which okay that's not that weird
um they're trying to start like a
kingdom of heaven on Earth again not
that unusual
uh they believe in the Universal
salvation of all people who are good and
evil living and dead
and um by the way there was also
somebody we're not saying who uh but
someone that was born in Korea in the
early 20th century that
um is basically like the second coming
of Jesus and he's like the Messiah and
he's like he's come to like finish
the job that Jesus couldn't finish which
I'll get into a little bit a little bit
later
um I think that Moon actually didn't
come out and say oh by the way spoiler
alert it's me I don't think he came out
and said that until like the 1990s but
I'm pretty sure that everybody was like
on board with that kind of whole thing
like he's like he's hitting he's into me
but yeah it was it was that kind of
situation
so uh moon was actually born in 1920 and
actually what is now North Korea
now his big claim was that on Easter day
of 1936 when he was 16 years old
Jesus appeared to him
all right
and asked him to assume the
responsibility for
establishing God's Kingdom on Earth it's
on you now
he passed the torch along
now uh as I said the Moonies have kind
of like a spiritualist element to them
as well in the sense that they believe
that they can communicate with
dead people like and they can Channel
dead people
so Moon said that he had communicated
with a whole bunch of other religious
figures including uh the Buddha and
Moses and also God himself because of
course
and uh
him Tom Right him talking to all those
people was what inspired him to write
the book The Divine principle because he
you know he was getting it all from high
up so you can't like question him on it
that came out in 1973 by the way
now when he started his little
sect
in the early days in Korea thank you
Zach I find it funny how any new
religion seems to get labeled occult and
only old religions get called religions
yeah it's
I kind of and I've seen it called it's a
little bit glib but there's probably
some truth to it it's just like you know
uh religion equals cult plus time
you know yeah which to a degree that
might be true cult has a negative
connotation but I don't believe that's
correct and I think uh Jenny or somebody
or earlier gave a definition of what
cult is
um
which doesn't quite match up with what I
remember the definition of a cult
was because nothing more than a small
religion it's smaller than a damn
denomination it was just cult
it didn't have anything to do with what
well no the thing about it was that well
the thing about it is that cult
it has two it has two definitions that
are that are both yeah you can use it in
the more general term yeah just meaning
like a small although I think that most
people if they meant it like that they
would just say sect yeah because because
that doesn't have any baggage attached
to it but they're smaller than a sect it
was a there was it was something there
was a damn
assist it was systematized at one time
and this it was old language I think
later on they started saying well it
does this it does that it does I
remember it was just a very small
religious organization it was not
and what they're talking about it was
not um what do you call it
I don't want to say canonized uh it
wasn't recognized as a uh
what's the name of the [ __ ] when they
uh
never mind it just it wasn't big enough
to be called a religion a religion had
to be big
and old this occult was very small
um you're talking you know
under a couple hundred that's what a
religion was or that's what a cult was
but the thing about it is all the time
they changed definitely well yeah I mean
the definitions of where language
changes um you know it's it's a living
thing people use it and the way that
people use words is not the same as it
was yeah before you know what I mean
yeah the word gay used to mean happy
yeah uh so when you watch movies from
the 1920s and somebody's talking about
how gay something is it's like we
Snicker because that's like that word
doesn't mean that anymore but at one
time it did I kind of feel like maybe in
the old days and technically like I said
if you look it up in like the dictionary
the word cult does still have that
definition where it just means like a
small religious group or something like
that that's just like a general
definition but because we've had so much
more exposure to like negative
Cults and they all have a very specific
way of going about things than most
people when you say cult they just jump
to that definition a negative well yeah
but like I said that's just what happens
words the definitions of words change
over time like you know languages are
living yeah you know they they're not
dead on pieces of paper people use them
and the way people use words changes all
the time and you just gotta deal with it
small religious organizations have
certain characters small Cults they all
kind of have a a character to them in
general the same thing with small Elite
organizations and small Elite military
organizations they have a certain
character to them something about what
happens between a small group of people
that believe in something and all work
together and live together and they're
trying to get something done that's why
Scientology has the sea organ it's
paramilitary because there's a lot of
crossover between
the dynamic of a small military unit and
a cult yeah at a small religious unit
they're they're both on missions they're
both willing to give their lives and a
sacrifice that's what they're talking
about
um
doesn't necessarily and they all kind of
use the same
tactics if that's where you want to call
them because yeah the characters are
it's it's just it's and it seems like it
just evolves out of the needs of the
group and human nature it starts to I
don't really think they plan for it to
be that way it evolves into that because
it has to be that way
like these people are going to leave we
got to [ __ ] keep them up doing
something yes a lot of Cults I don't I
mean I don't really think
I mean Scientology might be an exception
because I do think Hubbard knew he was
starting I don't think that he knew how
it was gonna go because nobody knows how
shit's gonna go like when something
metastasizes to that degree
so I don't think there are that many
Cults that are planned from the ground
up
but
I mean you have a person with a
particular kind of personality and they
maybe they're very charismatic maybe
they're very you know they just have a
particular personality where they would
form that kind of thing and just they
fall along the same lines as like
various other I don't think they plan no
for most of the things but it just kind
of like evolves into that because that's
that's how it has to be that's one of
the yeah that's one of the ruts yeah
that human behavior like falls into
that's what I believe it is because
Scientology really started off as as the
list make a [ __ ] a wizard make a
[ __ ] a wizard um uh scam which
is Anton levate not Antelope uh [ __ ]
uh the other guy uh Aleister Crowley
if you give Aleister curly money
he he'd he'd level you up and make you a
wizard and you keep getting giving him
money he levels you up and levels you up
that's what all Scientology was making a
[ __ ] a wizard
I mean they were really just trying to
make money yeah [ __ ] yeah using the new
spiritual Technologies what they called
it
but it has to become a cult for to sell
those Services over time okay it has to
take on that character of what you would
associate with a cult restrictive
basically
and paramilitary almost and now that I'm
now that I'm thinking along those lines
I'm kind of thinking about
I'm kind of wondering if Sun myung-moon
if he believed his own [ __ ]
from the outside it kind of seems like
he did but I've read a couple of
interviews with people that knew him or
people that got out of the cult or
something like that and I kind of feel
like it might have been
maybe he believed it when he was a
teenager I don't really know
but I do kind of feel like it did turn
into a money-making Enterprise much like
Scientology did yeah I'm of the belief
that in general they believe their own
[ __ ]
then they start getting success making
money buying all these [ __ ] buildings
and then creating an Empire and then
they go well this has to be from God
or or I wouldn't have thought yeah it's
like a self-fulfilling yeah like
prophecy God's with me you know I mean
he's making this happen whatever I say
is the word of God I'm channeling the
power of God I am God he starts going
that way
you know but then they Wonder really or
is this just or am I just riding a wave
that I've [ __ ] created do you really
think they have that much
self-reflection uh depends on what their
IQs are they probably would say they're
at least 135 IQ most of them to do that
because some some of them I think they
do like because which in a way like if
they have the self-reflection that means
they're doing it for cynical reasons if
they don't have the self-reflection then
they actually do actually believe
they're in [ __ ] I think they believe
it I think they believe their own
[ __ ] because they see the success
and then and then eventually they might
start to question it and go
what's you know
I started this ball rolling is it just
me creating this and maybe they just go
it doesn't might get to the point where
they just resolve it by saying it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter if this
is real or not it's working
might just be that
yeah you know
I guess it's different in every
situation like depending on the person
but I kind of think Moon believed it
he did seem to yeah although I'm pretty
sure L Ron Hubbard believed it but I
also I think he started off as a scam
yeah I don't think he believed it at
first no and I think over time he
believed it based on how he died what
they said about him I believe that he
believed it that
he thought he had conjured something
that really existed
that oh this is real a channel if it
wasn't real hilarious this would have
never worked you know
it's kind of hilarious when you start
some [ __ ] like that's all I mean it's
kind of like [ __ ] up too but it's also
kind of Darkly hilarious I guess they're
like you start some cult it's like hey
I'm just gonna like cha-ching I'm just
gonna like cash in on some like dumb
asses yeah and then you end up dying
like in your in a trailer somewhere like
believing that you're actually like the
[ __ ] he died in a trailer filled with
[ __ ] suitcases filled with cash
um basically semi-coherent
trying to channel alien souls and
speaking to alien Souls on an e-meter
Jesus Christ which tells me he believed
that [ __ ] if I ever go like that please
okay he believed that [ __ ] and I don't
think he believed it at first
I think he no I don't think he did
either right which like I said makes it
even more
sad slash hilarious is that he started
it out very cynically yeah well he
called himself the source of all that
teachings the source so he's channeling
it through alien souls and [ __ ] so he
believes it eventually other people
believed it
I could never imagine being arrogant
enough to like get into that kind of
mindset I just can't imagine it
is surrounded you are it's just totally
antithetical to my whole entire
personality you did not build a damn
Empire of huge buildings and you are not
surrounded by suitcases and suitcases
and suitcases of cash that they bring
you every day then you'd get arrogant
you'd get arrogant real I don't think I
would though I don't think I would
though well I wouldn't do that to start
with I've got to be doing something
right look at this I wouldn't do that to
start with because that's just like not
I guess I am that's like that's like
antithetical to my entire being I can't
imagine ever not me unless unless I fell
on my head and like [ __ ] changed my
entire personality like I just don't
think that would happen they know I'm
just not I'm just not like that I'm just
not like that they know better than to
give a [ __ ] like me that kind of
money I'd be Godzilla my head would be
the [ __ ] size for them well I know
you would but I'm not like that I'm just
not you know me I'm not like that
I have a [ __ ] army tanks and [ __ ]
yeah
dudes the flamethrowers
I'm like a religious rate religious it
could be religious warlord you seem
exactly the kind of person that would
form a cult yeah yeah you seem exactly
like no you know and I'm not you're
saying that to like be mean or anything
like that it would happen without me
[ __ ] realizing it you're just not
kind of like you have that personality
type I don't yeah you know what I mean
yeah because you're kind of like that
and you're also kind of like funny and
charismatic and like you have all that
and you're really outgoing and [ __ ] like
it would start by accident and it would
grow and then you would get like all
fully yourself then I'd start once that
ball started rolling it's snowball and
get bigger and bigger and the next thing
you know I'm [ __ ] trying to challenge
[ __ ]
yeah I'm the king of the world I'm a bad
man you know I'm [ __ ] up there and
the next thing you know I'm the trying
to say I'm the legitimate government of
this land yeah hell yeah don't have him
run anything I know him he wouldn't how
could you ever try to be a government
next to me okay that's how big my head
would get
with suitcases of cash I mean even
without suitcases of cashier already
kind of like that
he doesn't even need cash or power or
anything he's already I learned that
[ __ ] from [ __ ] Cassius Clay man
Muhammad Ali he's all right
who's the original [ __ ] talker
yeah Tom could totally start a cult
where I was like why don't you start
me
and I'll bring the Poltergeist in on it
and move some [ __ ] so that's what I mean
yeah you see well because it would be
better if you if it was part of your
personal experience you know what I mean
you could like kind of feel like like
you could totally [ __ ] you could sell
that
you could I mean it'd be enough for like
I don't know if you could make like a
million dollars not that [ __ ]
I have a conscience I can't do that kind
of stuff but you don't so yeah I have a
comment no I would I would only say
things I believed in
yeah well that's well that turns out
better for this game anyway yeah it's
always better to take what I believe
that's what I kind of feel like the
Cults that I think get really big are
one sees people like believe their own
[ __ ] because if you believe your own
[ __ ] then you can make other people
believe your [ __ ] also well
sometimes it's also based in things that
actually happen so it seems and the
thing about it too is that particularly
with you know Moon and with L Ron
Hubbard and stuff like that it's like
sometimes even if you thought it was
even if you started the whole thing like
as this game to start with but the more
you repeat it and the more you're like
immersed in it like you know the more
real it seems do you so yeah so after a
while you will like OT Powers Yeah OT
powers and I had to look at the details
of OT powers
I think the lower levels of the OT
powers
they probably work but it's not OT
Powers it's just the way it's just the
way human nature is you know I mean if
you communicate with people then things
happen I think that's and the way I see
[ __ ] Scientology is communicating
that's not really that's not really how
you do it but that's the way they want
to do it look we got to get back on
[ __ ] track stay on target that's a
stay on target
why start now that's true why start now
I mean [ __ ] we're already going with
like an hour and a half yeah it's like
I've only got like I've only gotten that
far down
so so yeah so this guy starts his little
religious movement in Korea
now from the beginning it met with a lot
of opposition
from all the established churches
obviously because it was seen as like
heretical or whatever and the government
officials weren't like super happy with
it either he actually got imprisoned uh
several times he was in a communist
labor camp for two and a half years so
there was that because like I said this
was North Korea at the time yeah
um now in the late 1950s he actually had
enough of a group to like send
missionaries out to Japan and he sent
some to the West as well and that kind
of like worked on like low-key but
really
um it didn't really get big I kind of
feel like until he moved to the U.S in
like
1972. you know what I mean so because
prior to that I feel like most people
had never heard of it because it was
going on like way the [ __ ] over there
you know what I mean but he moves to
like the US in 1972 And obviously in the
late 60s and early 1970s which we've
talked about on some of our other cult
shows there were a lot of people that
were looking for that were
disillusioned with you know traditional
or organized religions the weird thing
about this one though is that Moon's
religion I kind of feel like from my
atheist uh standpoint
to me this doesn't seem all that
different from like the regular ass
vanilla you know
Christian Presbyterian types well like
we're just very very conservative
traditional Christian it doesn't seem
that different or that off the wall
now they did attract some of the kind of
counter-cultural people but mostly the
counter-cultural people that were like
well we like like this new movement
thing but we don't want to go too crazy
like we don't like all the drugs and the
free love and everything like that
because this cult did definitely not
have that this was very much like no sex
before marriage that kind of stuff so it
wasn't even a fun cult you know yeah I
kind of feel like they didn't really get
and um the thing about it too
is that I mean he came over here and he
kind of got pretty well known
um I kind of vaguely remember hearing
about him when I was a kid like in the
70s he would do like big rallies and
like lecture tours and [ __ ] like that
and he would have big like [ __ ]
dinners where he would have all these
important people there and he also like
you know when Watergate happened and
like Nixon was in big trouble like he
came out and like was like oh God loves
Richard Nixon and he was like defending
Richard Nixon so I'm sure that probably
didn't endear him to a lot of like the
hippie types but he totally did do that
so I kind of feel like he got a lot of
media attention for that as well and
maybe I don't know I don't know if
that's maybe like where
where he really like got more popular
but you know
now much like Scientology they also
bought up a bunch of
kind of um
high profile properties I guess
um they bought the New Yorker Hotel
which as far as I know they still own
and the Tiffany building in Manhattan I
don't know if they own that still but
they did for a Time
uh so they got those and then as I
mentioned earlier they also had these
other like business I'm not really
entirely sure like where all the money
was coming from
I don't think anybody knows because they
got an alike on a lot of financial
trouble later on
but they started doing like they had a
big uh Fishing Company like I said and
they were
I don't know if they were actually the
first
group that got Sushi like popularized in
the United States but they were
definitely among the first uh because
that was like part of their concern so
they were just kind of trying to get
everybody to eat that and they had like
a bunch of like stuff like ginseng and
all this other kind of like tea
companies and things like that so they
had all kind of like front groups even
from those Early times you know I mean
like even from the 1970s
and then they also had as I mentioned
they had like ballet companies and dance
troops and like all kind of [ __ ] like
that like publishing companies that
didn't on the surface like have anything
to do with the religion and like you
wouldn't actually know that it was owned
by them like unless you knew a lot about
it so
I kind of feel like I it's weird because
I kind of feel like almost
he almost seemed to know that it's like
the message he was pushing because his
thing I don't I don't know if you guys
know but the moon's thing was like he
basically wanted to
unify the world in the sense that he
wanted like a one world theological
government essentially that's what he
was shooting for
so
I guess like he had all these business
and stuff because maybe he knew that
that end goal wouldn't be palatable to a
large portion of people so he was trying
to like attack on as many fronts as
possible I'm not sure if he like thought
of it in those terms but that's kind of
what it seems like
um but yeah they even have like they
their own Theological Seminary that like
uh you know came in like 1975 I think
um they opened like he opened
universities like in the 90s like in
Korea
and there was actually like a University
of Bridgeport in Connecticut which
actually
um they he didn't found it but it had
been there since the 20s but it was um
going bankrupt and he bought that up and
[ __ ] like that I don't know if he owns
that anymore but he did for a while
um just all kind of stuff like I said I
think most people know that he owns the
Washington Times the conservative
newspaper uh he you know started that in
1982.
um Ed but he owns like a bunch of other
like newspapers a bunch of media Outlets
things like that
um and the thing about it too is that as
I said they started doing
kind of the same kind of stuff that
scientologists were doing that children
of God were going doing stuff like that
the Mormons were doing like they would
send these very good looking
well-dressed young people
um out into the streets of the United
States and Europe and they would be
selling things they would sell like
candy bars or flowers or plants or
things like that and yeah probably yeah
uh like I said one one guy I watched an
interview with him who would actually
like you know he had been born in it
like I said so it was his parents that
got sucked into it not him but he was
saying yeah they totally did all that
love bombing thing and like that [ __ ]
have having people like approach like
good looking people approach other
people on college campuses and invite
them to things and like keep the
religion [ __ ] on the down low for like a
really long time because they were
really trying to like suck people in
now um people that joined in the 1970s
1980s um obviously a lot of them were
very white very middle class
um early 20s so like I said Mission
League college students because they
like to I mean and this is true of um
coltsinger and actually like religions
uh in a larger sense they like to
approach people who are at
transition periods in their lives
because I kind of feel like they're more
they feel like they're more vulnerable
or they're looking for something so
that's why they usually recruit in on
college campuses or sometimes
yeah airports right like people that are
you know undergoing change in their life
and maybe need some stability or
something like that they're always
looking for that little [ __ ] in the
armor somebody who just moved here
yeah something like that and like oh
maybe they're moving somewhere they
don't have any friends or maybe they
just got divorced or something like that
I always kind of feel like I feel like
that every time I see because every now
and then like around because there's
like a lot of Christian Billboards and
[ __ ] like that
and every now and then you'll see one
that is that's like oh you know is your
life shitty it doesn't say that but I
mean that's what they mean is your life
shitty like you know tell God this and
that and the other and I was just kind
of like well
I don't know I just I don't know that
why that pisses me off so much I'm like
they're always kind of just like
targeting the vulnerable
it's like is your life shitty it will
make your life even shittier Yeah by
taking all your money away they don't
see it that way they they see it as well
that's how I see it we're gonna help you
I'm like that's gonna make my life even
shitty thank you thinking of the of the
members at different or is different at
different levels you know what I mean
the people up top might know that what
the church has to expand because we got
to pay bills yeah the people at the
bottom so we need to help people they
all say that even the scientologists say
that well we're just trying to help yeah
we're just trying to help the world I'm
trying to help people
they're not helping people we're going
to clear the planet
at thirty thousand dollars ahead you
know it would be nice if they clear the
planet of themselves everyone would be
much happier but no if you guys what
we're talking about uh going clear is
making sure like it's kind of like being
saved or like confessing to that's the
Scientology version I guess you say like
being saved accepting Christ
you know that's kind of the equivalent
it's just entering the church
everybody into Scientology but when you
look at the details you got to pay for
that that's thirty thousand dollars so
they're going to clear the planet at
thirty thousand dollars ahead it ain't
gonna happen it ain't gonna happen good
luck getting 30. I don't think I've seen
thirty thousand dollars in my whole
entire life at one time yeah good luck
because that out of me
well that's another thing it's like
that's why well obviously I can never
get sucked into Scientology even if I
was uh you know kind of
primed for that kind of thing because
it's like they want money and I don't
have any so they wouldn't come after me
anyway but yeah Scientology was a rich
white man's uh religion at first yeah
Rich gullible white people
trying to become wizards no it's just
like I'm not like I said I'm not casting
aspersions on people that need
a sense of community or that need help
or so because everybody needs help or
they need somebody to talk to like it's
sometimes we're not like you know and
I'm no different in that regard but I
would never in a million years and as
far as I
and I've been like this as long as I can
remember it's like if somebody is coming
to you saying they know what's better
for you or like they can help you with
like and they don't know [ __ ] about you
or your problems
that is just like a big red flag to me
a lot of this stuff is not as appealing
as it used to be to the general public
because
um internet internet has interconnected
people they can you can any nobody feels
nowhere near as isolated it as they used
to you know people [ __ ] about the
internet like some but like cranky old
[ __ ] there is bad parts of you
sure but there's bad parts to everything
I would argue that it's like people that
cry it's like oh people just like
looking at their phones and [ __ ] like
that I'm like they're talking to other
people they're talking to people so it's
like you don't necessarily have to talk
to a person face to face to make that a
meaningful interaction I think things
are a lot better than they used to be
because people talk to each other more
you can find your tribe more yeah they
don't have to live by you like they used
to have to back in the old days yeah
the element of isolation is uh it's just
not really there you know there was some
good parts of it you actually had a lot
of peace and and sometimes ignorance was
Bliss
um yeah that's I'm that's that's the one
thing I don't like about the internet is
that I don't like feeling like I'm
24 7 like on with these [ __ ] yeah
because I because I feel like I'm
getting like you know texts all the time
and emails all the time it's like hey
can you do this for me and hey can you
do that for me and it gets like a lot
and it's like overwhelming but I
wouldn't want to go back to like the old
way
you have to you have to you have to make
an effort to pull yourself away from
these [ __ ] devices
I remember we used to just like set up
candles and put the candles on put on
some cool goth album and write a letter
to somebody or [ __ ] just chill out
and smoke and look out the window for a
[ __ ] couple hours and just chill out
time moves more slowly back then
remember that well it's probably because
we were younger we were younger too
because when you're older if you guys
aren't old right time moves quicker like
the older you get
but no you could have like [ __ ] weird
times of introspection thinking about
[ __ ] you know what happened last week
or that kind of [ __ ] you know what I
mean it's just
the times were different yeah but I
meditate like I said I do like it better
now
um there were good there were good
things about back then yeah but I kind
of feel like back then honestly back
then I felt more isolated because where
I grew up there weren't like a lot of
other people were into the same [ __ ] as
me I said I said so it was kind of
harder to like if you were into weird
[ __ ] and you lived somewhere where
nobody else was into weird [ __ ] and you
felt like really lonely because it was
like nobody around you could hang with
but it's like now you know if you could
have a friend like on the other side of
the world and y'all could do like a
[ __ ] Zoom call and it's like hey
let's have a cocktail and like watch
some [ __ ] scary videos
but you're also more motivated to go
[ __ ] see people I would [ __ ] rob I
would [ __ ] drive the car from [ __ ]
Heidelberg Mississippi all the way down
to the [ __ ] French Quarter New
Orleans all right that was like three
hours to go to a club
well yeah I used to do that too yeah I
used to live well when I lived in
Daytona I used to drive two and a half
hours each way yeah to Tampa to go to
the castle way down on Saturday you're
right and every Saturday yeah so it was
kind of a different time you know I mean
it was cool we were more motivated We
Were Young too you're more motivated to
[ __ ] travel long distances you know
distances that Europeans wouldn't
consider no you're [ __ ] driving
across [ __ ] swamps well it's a big
ass country it's a big country here well
in a particular where we lived it was
empty yeah particularly yeah it was
empty to be honest in the Southeast you
really really need a car yeah I grew up
here and I didn't have a car for a
really long time but it sucked you
couldn't go anywhere we got we got buses
but they took like a [ __ ] hour and a
half to get anywhere like even locally
it sucked bad I mean you know in the
Northeast it's a lot better things are
closer together and they have like
public transportation but down here the
public transportation is super shitty so
you have your own you have to have your
and everything is like really really
spread out and far apart he said the
Northeast was better I lived in both I
like I prefer the South it's just well
I'm just saying it's better it's better
for transportation yeah forgetting
places it's much quicker and easier down
here it's like if you want to go the
Northeast man the [ __ ] the population
density is high you can just get in a
Subway and go anywhere it's very
convenient but you got to do with the
downsides of being in a [ __ ] high
population density well everything's
attracted shoot guns or ride motorcycles
all year round to be honest I always
like spending time in big cities I
always enjoyed it I don't like
um crowds or I don't like being around
people but I don't really mind being
around people if I don't have to
interact with them I think the thing
that I liked the most about New York
City was that it was like super packed
but everybody just like kept to
themselves and like left you alone I'm
like that's awesome Boston was even more
New York those are those are the
outgoing people those people were
friendly compared to Boston well I'm not
saying they were you know I I found
people in New York very friendly but I'm
just saying that if you just wanted to
be left alone everybody got that like
everyone was just doing their own [ __ ]
and it's like yeah I got [ __ ] to do you
got [ __ ] to do I'm not gonna bother you
I'm not gonna like hang out in Boston I
liked that I lived in the Boston area
for six years other than Somerville and
Medford and uh I take new I lived there
for about six years seven years I'd take
New York over Boston any day I actually
like I've been to New York lots and lots
of times and I like it a lot I like it a
lot the people the people of new the New
Yorkers are the old New Yorkers I don't
know what it's like now I heard it's
kind of falling apart right now uh but
the old New Yorkers they were tough they
weren't scared of you you could just
start talking to them and run it with a
New Yorker in Boston they were mostly
from other places and they were shy
about being in a city and they're snotty
they're up in their own ass they had
money they had a lot of money they were
Rich especially on the red line not so
much the orange line but
on the red line they were up their own
asses
um I'd take New York New York was more
my my thing I lived in Detroit for a
while I liked Detroit but [ __ ]
grafters will tell you the Detroit was
[ __ ] Mad Max that was like the
Apocalypse but it was fun
it was fun for for the goth scene it was
like right out of the crow that's why
the crow was [ __ ]
um
set there I was there in the crow days
in the late 80s
oh somebody sent us a uh thank you Zach
yeah I so wish American towns and cities
were as walkable as those in Europe
especially with the flat footed Among Us
I am flat-footed too so I understand and
honestly well that's the thing never
happened I don't like to drive yeah
um so that's one thing that's one of the
things that I loved about being in New
York City even being like I really liked
um Philadelphia also when I was there
because it's like you could walk
everywhere or just like you could walk
to the subway and take and Europe was
like that too like when I was in Wales
or in England you could just kind of
like walk a mile or two like get a train
you go wherever the [ __ ] you wanted to
go and I thought that was like super
awesome and I just thought that was like
way more convenient
um I don't like I said I don't like to
drive I don't particularly like driving
on highways and if you live in the
Southeast you have to have a car because
everything is spread out and everything
is like sprawl and it's suburbs it's
kind of like Florida is kind of like la
it's not as big but
it's just a pain in the ass it's like if
you want a job if you want like anything
like you have to have a car like if you
have to rely on public transportation
you're [ __ ] or you're gonna have to
like wake up two three hours before you
have to be at work to take the bus there
and transfer
it's a pain in the end Florida doesn't
have the population density of valet of
La though no but it's similar like it's
like you know foreign
if you look at the map most of it's like
this Suburban would be
Altamonte well that's kind of what I was
talking about yeah okay I don't think
most of us like that though
I think most of it's like this because
most of it's empty
most of Florida is a empty swamp well
Florida
it's very very it's very very developed
along all the coasts obviously
the middle part not so much and the
Panhandle is the same as Mississippi and
Alabama and Louisiana it's
the same kind of people it's the same
culture
which is not bad it's just what it is uh
but
when you go to Orlando and on down
you're basically dealing with Central
America it has a very Central American
Vibe and being grown up partially in
Brazil it feels very much like Central
and South America it's got a real good
mix good flavor is very positive
optimistic it was optimistic place
um we got to get back to the thing
though we got to get back to we're
talking too much about about yeah about
the moon yeah
getting drunk yeah I see that yeah so
let's talk about a little bit about the
Moonies beliefs
so as I said uh Reverend Moon said that
he got uh he channeled
all of these give Moses god everybody
the Buddha and he wrote this book about
all this important [ __ ] that they told
him
so he's offering like I said it's a
Christian denomination it's it's not
that different it's not that crazy from
like regular Christian [ __ ] at least
from my point of view
um he's offering an interpretation of
the Bible that can re can unite all
religions which like I said good luck
with that that's never going to happen
but okay
so in their in their theology
so it's like we'll get you some wine bro
I gotta go to the restroom
so in their theology God is actually
portrayed as a personal being
and his whole thing this is a little bit
different I guess from traditional
Christian theology
but creation according to uh according
to the Moonies
it has positive and negative or male and
female evidence guess which one is
negative the female of course because it
always is
so
um basically Adam and Eve
God created them so
that he could have like a kind of
relationship with them I guess which you
know we're getting into some weird area
here
so his original plan according to the
Moonies
was that Adam and Eve were supposed to
get to a state of perfection
and then they were going to marry and
have children
and then their children's children would
populate the world and their children
would be sinless like it was kind of
implied I guess I mean I could be
reading this wrong but like from what I
read of their theology
it seems like they're saying that Adam
and Eve
had sin I guess but like when they
procreated like that their children
would be sinless and then therefore all
of the children vents forth that would
populate the Earth would be sinless so
that the Earth would be sinless like all
the humans would be I think that's what
they're saying
so um so that was the original plan but
that's not what happened
what happened was there was
um a fall of humanity but not
necessarily because of like eating the
apple or the Fig or whatever it is like
from the Tree of knowledge no
what happened apparently was that the
Archangel Lucifer
who God had
you know said hey go look after those
two Adam and Eve
what happened was that Lucifer uh got
jealous
of God's love for
Adam
and had
sex with Eve
either literally or figuratively I'm not
entirely sure like this religious stuff
is very nebulous so I'm just saying I
don't know if he actually like [ __ ]
her like in real life or if it was just
kind of like
I don't know or like a spiritual [ __ ]
I don't know if it was like that
so there was that and then Eve then said
hey
um you should have sex with me like
physically and that was bad apparently
so because this sex that they had
happened before God had deemed that they
were mature enough for this whole like
you can have sinless babies now [ __ ]
um then The Offspring that they had
was apparently like Lucifer centered
rather than god-centered so this is
essentially kind of like a variation on
the original sin
theme kinda so like all of the kids that
they have are like born in descent
pretty much because they're Lucifer
tainted I guess
so
from their point of view they see all of
history
um
as essentially like uh an attempt by
both God and humans to kind of get back
to what God originally intended I kind
of feel like if God was God whatever he
intended that's what would have happened
because no yeah no you're reading too
much into it
why do you always tell me that because
the god of the Old Testament was a God
that walked around a garden trying to
cool off in the middle of the garden he
made Adam and Adam is basically his
Gardener all right well you're talking
about it you trimmed those Hedges man
you're talking about a middle eastern
potent tape yeah okay I'm gonna run to
the bathroom he he uh go ahead and
played commercials no Mickey Mouse I'm
not talking I'm gonna sit here and talk
yeah okay she's trying to get me to talk
and Now's the Time Now's the Time
actually to play commercials
and um
basically basically
if you look at the Old Testament
in a Genesis
even actually beyond what they're
describing as a middle eastern potentate
somebody who would be running a
city-state
you know he's got a garden
uh he's got a gardener Adam
he walks around during the day
in the cool of the day
which I don't know when the cool of the
day is but I believe that's what it said
um
uh what else does he have he's got hands
and feet he's got a face he has a back
and a back side which I guess that might
be the ass it's hard you're talking
about a giant man
that's that's what's being described
so
if you compare that to other religions
what you're talking about is Zeus you're
talking about the Middle Eastern or the
near Eastern
version of Zeus
now when he creates Eve
okay she's coming back
why are we talking about no when he
creates Eve uh he creates a mate for but
then later she gets um uppity
well serpent comes in
well yeah everybody knows this about the
serpent now the serpent modern Christian
mythology is always said to be Satan and
Reverend moons made that same mistake
the serpent was not Satan the serpent is
asherah and Ashura was um
Yahweh or El Shaddai which is basically
the Canaanite
the Canaanite uh version of Zeus god you
know God it's translated in the in the
in the in the Septuagint or the Greek
old the Greek Old Testament as uh God
Almighty but if you look at the original
text it says El Shaddai
ashra was his wife and we have statues
of ashra and it's a woman carrying
serpents
yeah all right that's who it is there's
lots of statues lots of statues over and
they the Jews had oshara polls for a
long long time all the way into the damn
Roman period all right
uh in this story
God's wife is demoted into a demoted
into a serpent
for uh
allowing human beings to have knowledge
it's basically a retelling of the tale
of Prometheus God wants everyone to be
dummies yeah
they're making all that goddamn noise
and he's like why'd you even create him
in the first place yeah
well
[Laughter]
our stories of God in the Old Testament
and everything they're the hillbilly
version of hillbilly versions of the
stories of Zeus yeah Canaanites were
just [ __ ] Hillbillies
one of those cave and Canaanite tribes
was basically ended up well okay
Judaism came from that
Pantheon of religions they they
worshiped all different kinds of gods
um they make it sound like Judaism goes
back to the Old Testament times that you
know that
that it's 6 000 years old no no modern
Judaism is probably medieval
that's probably not that old
well modern Christianity modern
Christianity is not that old from the
medieval period
that's when it was kind of cute about it
into one thing go back 2 000 years you
know to the Roman period you wouldn't
recognize Christianity you wouldn't
recognize you wouldn't recognize Judaism
either
there's a bunch of different versions of
them of Judaism a bunch of different
just like there were different versions
of the Greek religions
one of the versions of of Judaism that
the Romans were constantly fighting were
zelots that's what it's who what the
zealots came from they were on par with
like Isis
they were these
Savages man
cutting people's heads off and setting
them on fire and they did anything to
them get rid of the Roman authorities
they didn't want to be part of Roman
Empire
okay now you can go back commercials
over all right yeah oh that was a
commercial that was a commercial for for
religion yeah
you're not you're not making anybody
want to buy it it's a lot better [ __ ]
history is a lot better than religion
okay I always thought so yeah well like
I said archeology backs up what I'm
saying archeology does not back up
anything out of the the Torah the
septuagen the [ __ ] Old Testament no
there's no archeology although I have
been wanting to do a show about quote
unquote biblical archeology because
that's a whole we ought to do it yeah
that's a whole like sub-genre where
people have claimed that they've found
this that and the other thing
um you know oh we found the ark we found
this that and the other and it's uh
that's also fascinating to me but yeah
like I said mythology is fascinating to
me history is fascinating to me
and
you're you're ruining the fun by trying
to like cram that into like a reality
kind of framework it's a narrative
that's not what it's for it's not what
it's for yeah that's all I'm saying all
right
so uh so yeah so basically yeah so the
so the moon you see everything as
we're all attempting to get back to this
what God intended as I said
now
of course it and this is where the
Moonies come in this is where River moon
comes in
the only way we can fix this [ __ ]
get it back to what God intended from
the beginning but [ __ ] up for all this
time
was that we need a messiah wonder who
that could be
this Messiah whoever it is
um and his wife
will
perform the roles which Adam and Eve uh
failed to perform thank you Zach I might
rag on some religions but I adore the
art and some culture and some stories
have come out of them yeah yeah like
look my
my one of my favorite parts of the met
when I go to New York is the medieval
art like they're all the religious art
and the stained glass and all that kind
of [ __ ] I love that [ __ ] I love like
Cathedrals I love the Catholic imagery I
love all this stuff I'm believing that
stuff is true but it's beautiful El
padrino is asking me about the library
of Alex my thoughts on the Library of
Alexandria there may have been a library
about did we do a show about that no we
probably should there may have been one
um
the Ancients claim that there was a
library of Alexander and there are a lot
of things that are lost from that time
and that that burned but there's no way
of knowing now we did a show on um Ivan
the Terrible's life that's what I was
thinking yeah that was a while he was
evidently had a bunch of books and we
even have a list of the titles of the
books they were lost books
and uh
some of them were alternate titles
different versions of books that we have
but they he had the older versions
And he supposedly buried it into in the
tunnels underneath the Kremlin
and that people have looked for him
they'd look for him during the Soviet
period they risked their own lives we
haven't found anything but it's flooded
that means shit's not there you know
it's flooded and I'm having a terrible
hit it down there or I haven't agreed
depending on what you want to call him I
think he's great I don't think he's
terrible I think he's great he just
didn't want to [ __ ] with him okay okay
you did not want to [ __ ] with that man
better than being I've in the mediocre
yes
Russians were always a very special
breed of white people okay if you [ __ ]
with Ivan he had a special huge frying
pan manufacturer I cast iron frying pan
you know he'd tie your ass up and Fry
you alive and he'd had dudes that would
flip you over to the other side like
your name like a pancake
evidently look like a frying pan and
everything it was like a human size
human it was several people could fit in
I mean if it wasn't horrifying that's
imagine that that's really kind of funny
you did not you never ever ever I don't
give a [ __ ] you're gonna see it people
do not [ __ ] with those Russians all
right they have a very good history of
[ __ ] getting the bed review over time
all right they [ __ ] got they they use
winter and time against you and
intelligence well I mean they're used to
like the winter so they just they've
been invaded many times it's a war of
attrition yeah and they they do not care
about getting hurt or getting killed
they just don't they just keep coming
El pedrina said that we should do a
shirt of you like pointing at you like
Uncle Sam that says don't get sporty
with me don't get [ __ ] sporty with me
so many shirts right after you you guys
come up with all kinds of [ __ ] funny
ideas
yeah that would be a good one and the
funny thing is Tom doesn't even remember
obviously
yeah he's very [ __ ] up all right so
where was I okay so Adam and Eve failed
in their duties obviously because
Eve had
either actual sex or maybe like
imaginary spiritual sex with Lucifer
which was bad and then she like made
um Adam have sex with her which and then
they had a kid and then that would but
it was too early you know what I mean
because God didn't approve
so they [ __ ] up and God was mad
so basically that's kind of like the
whole tenet of their thing because the
whole thing is that because they [ __ ]
up now we're just waiting on another
Messiah
Guess Who and his wife to
you know kind of fix that problem we're
gonna fix that problem and these people
are going to be called the true parents
and yes eventually Moon and his wife did
call themselves that because you know
why not
ego knows no bounds I guess
so basically whoever these true parents
were not naming any names but they said
who like will be the true parents and
whoever we bless in marriage which we'll
get into in a minute because I kind of
feel like the Moonies everybody knows
them from that like the mass wedding
ceremonies that was the first time I
heard about them I think now that I'm
thinking about it
um yeah so whoever they bled that's
gonna be kind of like they're that's
going toward their end goal of like
taking over the world with all their
sinless
Offspring essentially they're they're
just trying to like make a bunch of
offspring that don't have any uh
original sin like uh you know attached
to them
so uh they also have a thing where they
don't think that this will be able to
come about until everybody is ready for
the Messiah to arrive and there's also
kind of a thing that they call indemnity
and this is a thing where if you do like
a really good deed like you sacrifice
yourself for someone else or something
like that then this is supposed to
cancel out all the bad [ __ ] you've ever
done
oh and not just what you've ever done
but also what your ancestors did
okay so that's kind of like a tenant as
well
so basically what they believe
is that Jesus was supposed to be the guy
who had a wife and had a bunch of
sinless children
okay
hi pookie
she's like hey
but because he got killed and crucified
um he wasn't able to like he [ __ ] it
up he wasn't able to like fulfill
the role that he was supposed to so
somebody else got to come along
to step into that role and you know
guess who that is guess who that is I do
admire
I don't admire the Reverend Moon I
admire the Reverend moon for having the
restraint to not actually come out and
say hey I'm actually the Messiah until
like 1992. that's when he officially
said even though he had the church going
until since like the 50s
so I was like that's some amazing
restraint right there even though but I
kind of feel like he was just dancing
around it the whole entire time oh you
know there's this story about you know
how Jesus like he was supposed to have a
family and he was supposed to have some
kids that were sinless and stuff but he
got crucified so that whole thing got
[ __ ] up but so there's supposed to be
like another Messiah
that forms this family and they have
like all these children we're gonna
populate the earth with like all these
sinless Offspring
um you know maybe who could it be I I
don't I don't know I don't know who
could it be who do you think it is you
know what I mean
[Laughter]
Tom's not getting it
this whole [ __ ] Messiah thing okay
you talking about Messiahs yeah
Christians have kind of a incorrect
concept of what a messiah is when you
say Messiah to a Christian they think of
Jesus coming back
because that's
that was that was the Christian
expectation
the word is meshia which means basically
military leader or Commander
and in Old Testament and in Jewish lore
a mashiach is a military basically a
[ __ ] military dictator that rises up
to save
Israel okay
a messiah could be anybody
I mean she is just
a savior you know it's not necessarily a
supernatural thing
but somehow Christians started to
believe that Jesus would come back as
their Messiah
so therefore Alma she is if you say
you're a meshia you're you're Jesus
that's not what that means you know
that's not what that word means
it's just you know
it's insinuated that it's Jesus so what
moon saying he's a meshia yeah okay he's
a messiah all right it doesn't mean he's
Jesus
but that's what but he's not saying he's
Jesus he's saying that he is
that Jesus
um came to Earth this is what I was
explaining that Jesus came to Earth and
he was supposed to
marry and have children that were going
to be sinless and he was going to like
establish God's Kingdom on Earth but he
got crucified so that [ __ ] up that
whole plan yeah so now moon is saying oh
well I'm the new one like I'm the one
that's gonna but like I said he didn't
come out and say that officially until
1992. although like I said he kind of
like hinted around it prior to that okay
well in the Canon with that lore you
could say that
well he did say that you could say that
and it worked yeah because several
thousand people believed him and gave
him money yeah so
you can say anything he he's basically
saying he's a messiah well yeah that's
what he's saying yeah he's just saying
I'm the next one I'm the replacement
because Jesus [ __ ] up his mission
because he got he got murdered right
that's what he's I'm doing improved
that's what he's saying right I'm the uh
I'm [ __ ] Jesus 2.0 yeah essentially
the first one was [ __ ] up I'm gonna
fix it yeah it didn't happen yeah the
way it was supposed to right and you
know what he's in Canon
yeah the Bible has a lot there's a lot
of wiggle room in there yeah you can
come up with a lot of
um yeah you know you can come up with a
lot of in-universe
stories and they still work with all of
the all of them you can go you can go
into the revelations and there's gonna
be warnings their prize from warnings in
the Pauline material about hey don't
listen to false prophets and don't
listen to false this and that and uh
Machias are going to rise first thing
that falls and he's gonna and and
they're gonna and and if you were to
come at the moon and go wait a minute it
says right here we're not supposed to
listen to false prophets and [ __ ]
two-bit Machias and [ __ ] like that you
know he's gonna go oh yeah no yeah
that's correct the thing is is that I'm
not a false Messiah
is that pretty much every like that I
know of maybe there might be some
exceptions
but everyone that has come forth and
said they were in the Messiah that
they'll come right out the gate and
quote that [ __ ] yeah immediately yeah
because they know people are going to
quote that because so it's like they'll
come out at first and be like oh well
everybody will tell you yada yada but
that's not me not me because I'm the
real thing because I'm the real thing
you've seen it yourself yeah they know
what they're doing yeah they know what
they're doing I mean it's all a scam but
they know what they're doing but you
know but you got to know your [ __ ] you
have to know you have no scripture to to
know like
to know at least pretend you know
scripture or at least no scripture as
the way your followers know it and no
yeah which like I said um I kind of feel
like like no offense but I do kind of
feel like a lot of people that uh most
Christians don't know bash the Bible the
hardest have never read the [ __ ]
thing yeah
yeah and there's a lot of people a lot
of people that really follow it who
really believe all of it don't know it
nope
not at all
I took a quiz one time
my atheist ass did like way better yeah
on the Bible quiz yeah then okay let me
ask some of you Christians out there I'm
gonna ask you a question real quick off
top your head you can answer in the cry
in the comment section
according to the New Testament can you
eat meat
sacrificed to an idol
can you is it okay
and that's the question okay go ahead
thank you Zach that gives more money
yeah if you went to somebody's house
a Roman in the ancient time and they
mean
making steak on the grill and then
you're looking at the steak and you go
wait a minute hold on
this steak was sacrificed to the [ __ ]
to an idol it was sacrificed in in the
honor of [ __ ] Emperor [ __ ]
uh Tiberius
or something or something
can you eat that and be a Christian and
that's the question
yeah
like I said I I kind of feel like yeah a
lot of people just kind of know what
they're told and they don't actually
read the [ __ ]
[Music]
tell you
and I'm gonna tell you all the questions
wait are you gonna spoil I'm gonna spoil
it don't spoil it
it says yes and no
in one place it says
well as long as you know that those
Idols are not real and you're a
Christian then yeah you can eat it but
God finds out he's gonna [ __ ] kill
you
it says yes and no in two different
places don't throw your ass yeah in one
place hell no you can't eat [ __ ] in
order to buy it are you crazy and then
another place that goes now as long as
you know that those guys are why are you
even asking that question yeah yeah well
you can do it
too many rules man oh hey they're giving
us more money I know that's what I just
said what's up Zach Zach's breaking it
off I know right okay thank you very
much you're doing all right Zach what do
you say he says I think two of my
favorite things from World art and
culture are Orthodox icons yeah and the
hairstyles from African Hair Braiding I
have no idea why uh one of my favorite
things actually are illuminated
manuscripts which were usually Bibles
like from the Medieval Era and also
stained glass windows from Catholic
churches also from the Medieval Era
which are two of my favorite things
artistically yeah all right now uh
slides asked me do you guys think that
Cleopatra's graves in that tunnel
underneath the Temple of Osiris in Egypt
I would say absolutely not no I doubt it
no [ __ ] I mean I don't know but I
doubt it Cleopatra was not an ancient
Egyptian she was a modern Egyptian
during the Roman period all that stuff
was [ __ ] thousands of years a
thousand two thousand years older than
than
by the time Cleopatra was around that
[ __ ] was already 2 000 years old at
least
which is crazy she had nothing to do
with that yeah
Cleopatra was also not Egyptian
no she was a Ptolemy which she was a she
was a Greek she was a great kid the
Romans conquered Egypt and gave
basically governorship
over Egypt to a Greek family that was
Allied to Rome known as the ptolemies
and she was one of the ptolemaic rulers
she did have some Egyptian blood in her
but she was Greek she did sport some of
the some of the Egyptian motifs and
clothings and her ways but she was she
was a great she was she was the foreign
ruler in charge of Egypt
and probably not all that good looking
well they do have coins of her face and
yeah she's a little bit of a butterface
a little bit well I mean I don't know if
like the people that made the coins
didn't like her so they made her look
uglier than you but she's a little bit
of a butterface
Caesar uh she's uh what's his name first
Caesar Caesar
main Caesar the maintenance Caesar
number one Caesar one what was this
[ __ ] Caesar OG
yeah um
he met her he and he had a child with
her he said when he first saw her she
was attractive but not pretty but he
liked her
uh I kind of feel like she came across
as like more sexy than pretty he said
she was attractive but not pretty
um he liked her
yeah uh but another take on it is is
that there was a lot of evidence that
that uh Cleopatra Ptolemy was real
intelligent okay and uh very well
educated
uh especially for her day and especially
for a woman so
um
Caesar won but [ __ ] what's his name man
I've been drinking I can't remember
[ __ ]
uh that's the kind of woman he would
have liked and he was already married
people back in [ __ ] Rome were pissed
that he's he was [ __ ] around on his
wife I think her name was Julia
um had a child whether and everything
and that kind of that kind of [ __ ]
led to [ __ ] Julius excuse me Julius
uh they kind of let it probably
contributed to Julia's getting
assassinated because his son would have
been another heir to the throne at that
period because it was starting to go
into an imperial era and they didn't
want any more Challengers to get rid of
his ass and getting rid of that baby
would have [ __ ] help reconstitute
them man they would just like if you
were in line for the throne man the year
life was not worth anything they would
just knock you right the [ __ ] right they
had no compunctions about that at all
yeah and it was probably his [ __ ]
nephew Octavius who was his adopted son
who did that assassination because he
had the most a game always ask who gains
in anything even today who gains if
somebody dies chances are they say who
gained with [ __ ] Julius being killed
Octavius in other words Caesar Augustus
his his adopted son I think he did it
I think he had his I think he had him
killed
yeah I mean that doesn't always mean
that somebody had somebody assassinated
but in those situations probably yeah
and then the first thing he does is he
goes on a rampage and wipes out anyone
who is his suspected enemy
avenging his his father or his adopted
father well [ __ ] man you could you could
accuse a lot of [ __ ] potential
enemies of that so you could just clear
yeah and wipe out everybody and then he
declares himself imperator emperor all
right so yeah that was Octavian that did
that [ __ ] convenient yeah
because I mean transparent yeah because
Julius wasn't wasn't an emperor he was
dictator
you know he was he said he was a
dictator for life he was trying to
re-establish the Republic because it was
[ __ ] up
Samantha said I went to school in
Tarrytown New York we were
um every time I hear a Tarrytown New
York I always think of uh
Legend of Sleepy Hollow yeah we were a
Catholic College we were told to stay
clear of the Moonies
I mean really like realistically
everyone should steer clear the Moonies
and like any call please don't join me
to call you guys
seriously
where was I okay
so 1992 Moon finally comes out and says
what everyone would suspected all along
him and his wife are the true parents of
all Humanity who knew
he was our parents the whole time
now uh so basically what happens after
that
now after he announced that
was that uh he came out in 1993 and said
um oh by the way like not only are me
and my wife like the true parents
but we've also established the first
true family uh which would at that point
was him and his wife and his children
and his children had children so his
grandchildren as well
and that the world had entered into what
he called the completed Testament age
like they
they got past that point I guess they
they did that achievement and they were
moving on to the next achievement I
guess
so a couple years later
um he establishes this new thing which
is called toon dock hey and they would
kind of like read passages from his
speeches so I kind of feel like prior to
that he was kind of like going biblical
but like I don't know like extra
biblical but after this point he's just
like [ __ ] it now everybody's just gonna
like read my words and I'm the I'm the
God now I kind of feel like he went that
direction like as they usually do
so
um so basically yeah so 2004 he actually
announced uh what they used to call the
era before Heaven is now the era after
the coming of heaven so he's basically
saying well our family came and we
established all this [ __ ] you're welcome
um so now like Heaven's already here
essentially was what he was kind of
going for
um also like I said I kind of feel like
most people and this is where I kind of
heard about them first as well but their
marriage ceremonies
so
this is where because there was a big
one in the what was it the late 70s or
the early 80s that was a few thousand I
remember it was like all over the media
and I remember like a lot of people
talking about the Moody's at that time
because everybody Associated movies with
like these Mass weddings
now technically they weren't Mass
weddings because some of those people
were married already or it wasn't like a
legally binding it was ceremonial it was
just ceremonial so they usually called
it the blessing
but what they would usually do and like
I said they um
moon was very into arranged marriages he
did not believe in romantic love he did
not believe in people uh choosing their
own mates
he basically would uh match and I think
they still do it online nowadays please
uh you know correct me if I'm wrong but
I think they even have an online thing
where like they match you with you
the issue the issue you some [ __ ] yeah
like they don't give a [ __ ] if you don't
know that person or not it's all gonna
work out it's all gonna work out in the
end
so they marry you to this person that
you've literally only met it's kind of
like a reality show actually is there a
reality show like that like married
after three days or some [ __ ] I kind of
feel like there's a reality show like
that but so they do some [ __ ] like that
and then
in some situations I think they tell you
you got to be celibate for like 40 days
okay
and then you can start [ __ ] and then
like produce some like sinless children
you know what I'm saying
I don't know
yeah well like I said that was their
whole thing yeah that's their whole
thing because they say well well Adam
and Eve had sin still but it's like when
they had kids somehow they didn't have
any sin right so that's but then Jesus
was supposed to fix that and it was all
[ __ ] up I don't know like I said I
don't know
have that whole thing happen
now the first one of these Mass weddings
actually took place in 1961 and that was
uh in South Korea and that was 36
couples now Moon and his wife had just
married like the year before that so I
guess that's where they got the idea
now as I said
um those were mostly matched I think
there were a dozen of them who were
already married but they were just there
for the free food I don't know what they
were there for but so they were just
there for that now as it as the years
went on like the the ceremonies got like
bigger and bigger and like I said until
a point where in the late 70s early 80s
something like that I kind of feel like
the media took off with it because it's
weird right it's like all these big
[ __ ]
wedding things they even had one at
Madison Square Garden like that was in
1982 and then in 1988 they had another
one with
2500 couples that he actually
specifically like matched Koreans to
Japanese members because that was one of
his big things like I said one of his
big things is he wanted to unify
everybody
which like I said that's it sounds cool
but it's not really a good idea when you
think about it
um so he was trying to do like cross
cultural and like cross-racial kind of
um things because he wanted everybody to
believe the same thing so
he would take cultures that were
traditionally enemies and he would like
put them together so he would do that
kind of thing to you
to get like Unity between the Nations
so you know so there was that too
now the thing about it as I said I kind
of feel like this whole emphasis on
marriage is because
their whole thing is very very oriented
toward the family and
and how Moon and his wife are supposedly
like the true parents of all humankind
and their children are supposedly like
without sin and like you know just by
extension like whoever they give their
blessing to is also without sin
there was actually as recently as 2009
there was actually a uh one of these
Mass blessings that was 20
000 couples so there's that so as I
mentioned uh they're very very in their
you know views of marriage and their
views of gender politics and their views
of uh you know sexual anything they're
very very conservative they uh they
believe in sexual abstinence until
marriage
um and you know they don't believe in
cheating on
your wives even though obviously Moon
did that because of course he did
because you know that's one thing
they're always talking about them like
so oh well I don't believe that you
should like cheat on your spouse and
blah blah meanwhile they're [ __ ]
everything that moves because that's
essentially what they do that's one of
the things that happens in Cults well
yes and it happened in this one as well
sex power and money moved to the
Forefront
also like I mentioned earlier it will
not surprise anyone to know that this uh
cult is massively homophobic they do not
uh they have called gay people dirty
dung eating dogs and hoping that God
will be eliminated gaze will be
eliminated uh and purged on God's orders
so you know and there's probably all
kinds of gay people in there that's
always nice yeah I hope not probably all
kinds of gay people in there I hope not
but if they do if if you are they hate
you so get the [ __ ] out of there they
probably can't get out
that's
that's the well and the thing about it
and this makes me sad about scientology
too because it's like obviously like I
said nowadays I kind of feel like you
have to have like been living under a
rock like you know no offense but it's
like you have to have been living under
a rock to like join Scientology like as
a functioning adult
but I feel bad for people that were
raised in it yeah because it's very hard
to get out of something
that especially something like
Scientology or something like a
religious cult where you don't really
have a lot of outside influence so it's
not like very easy you know it's easy
for my stupid you know atheist ass to
like be out here and say oh just get the
[ __ ] out of there like what the hell are
you all their families in there but yeah
but it's like yo you know your whole
entire family is in there like your
whole entire childhood is tied up with
this belief system and it's like really
hard for you to get past that like I get
that then there's situations where you
got gay people who are believers who go
who join that stuff they're kind of like
a pray the gay away kind of thing well
if I go in there then I won't be gay
just like that movie we saw remember the
prayer of the Gateway movie that was a
good movie we saw it was yeah
the dude doing the gay conversion
therapy in the church was gay yeah I
kind of feel like that happens a lot
well because
here's what I like not always but I kind
of feel like a lot of times anybody that
worries that much about other people's
sexuality
yeah you're in Conflict about your own I
mean yeah that was a true story why
would you care though do you remember
the name that was one of the best movies
of the year it was called boy um and he
just came and went nobody even noticed
it
it was called boy something boy yeah
[ __ ] yeah we saw in the theater so
Nicole Kidman was in it yeah
it was really good I always did a lot I
know I never I'll remember in a second
all right so it's just cheap kind of
little movie it was a little Indie movie
yeah about they sent the kid to the gay
prayed the Gateway class those are
horrifying I can't imagine
I can't imagine like my because my
parents weren't like that at all but
it's like if they had like sent me to
some [ __ ] like that Holy it wasn't it
wasn't horrified they didn't hurt him or
kill him or anything no but it's like
still you were just trying to pray the
gay away and [ __ ] all kinds of
[ __ ] it doesn't have to be physically
abusive it could be emotionally abusive
the movie's [ __ ] funny especially if
you're especially out of [ __ ]
um vulnerable age like that because to
be honest when you're a kid
being told that you suck and like
everything that you like and care about
is wrong and it's just like that I mean
that really [ __ ] you up and it [ __ ]
you up for a long time like it's hard
for a lot of people to get over it I
don't really remember them telling him
that I just remember them they were just
doing a lot of praying
and then about Sin but then as the movie
unfolds and towards the end of it then
his parents were good to him his parents
and when the movie ends it's this true
story you know the guy who went through
it wrote the movie
to give like an update of every all the
characters and it turns out at the end
the dude that was running the [ __ ]
prey of the Gateway [ __ ] um course
for the church
just came out it's gay he's like yeah
he's getting into the theater I was like
ooh shocker yeah yeah I was not
surprised they're like yeah of course
because like I said any [ __ ]
that cares that much about who somebody
else is [ __ ] yeah
like you know you got a question got a
question why he was why do you care so
much about other people's sexuality he
wasn't mean though he was just trying he
he was he was he was conflict he was
trying to secure he was trying to cure
him it was and I guess it was just a
bunch of misdirected people you know
what they say the road to hell is paved
with good intentions yeah just it was
it's just everybody in all the
characters they were good people they
were just
making a big deal out of nothing that
kind of thing too yeah just making too
much big to nothing
which religious families do that they
[ __ ] won't let you listen to Judas
Priest and [ __ ] that's what I'm saying
they're not gonna let you just you know
I couldn't make a big deal out of that I
can't imagine yeah I don't know that
that whole mindset is just so [ __ ]
alien to me so they're worried about
what was something was written in
Scripture
yeah and they don't even really
understand what was written or the
context so they're just worried about it
yeah that's what I'm saying they're
afraid well they're not I mean they're
low information yeah yeah people they
were friends but they're very low
information
you know
and they're driven a lot by fear as well
I kind of feel like people like that are
just driven by like they're just afraid
of everything they're afraid of
something that's different from them
yeah
and
I don't know I just I'm not like that
and I don't get it and it's just I don't
know people like that just upset me like
like I said it just seems like an alien
concept to me it's just like [ __ ]
that doesn't have anything to do with
you just [ __ ] back
butt out like why why do you care I
don't get it but anyway
so so yeah so the whole
um marriage thing they're very very into
which as I mentioned earlier which is
why the whole Mooney situation why they
have found so much
honestly a lot of these stuff you know
how you know how we did the show about
the satanic panic and like that whole
thing where like the 80s like all these
like super like uh conservative like
church groups so we're all just like oh
satanic everything yeah
um yeah the Moonies were in on that kind
of [ __ ] too because they were all like
all their reviews aligned
they were very very much
um a very classic even though behind the
scenes all kind of [ __ ] was going on
like River moon was like [ __ ]
[ __ ] all kinds of people and like
justifying it and then just like his
sons were like beating up their wives
and doing drugs and running around [ __ ]
like that but they were doing the same
kind of [ __ ] that a lot of you know
funny Christians did like in the 80s
here too as well they were just kind of
like oh we're the perfect family unit
they were doing this going back to the
[ __ ] 50s I just put that [ __ ] I just
put that [ __ ] on human behavior people
want to be respected they want to do
what they think is right it's it's
another term of virtue signaling and
Christians love to [ __ ] virtue love
to Virtue signal just think I guess
everybody else does and some of the
early church fathers and some of the
Saints and [ __ ] movie
some of that stuff their virtue
signaling is how St Thomas Aquinas you
know Thomas Aquinas
his writings if he actually kind of look
at him his his Church's instructions I
mean that sounds awful gay
it just sounds awful gay to me it's it's
just you know don't have anything to do
with women don't have anything to do
with sex don't this is this is these are
gay dudes cloistering themselves away
with other dudes without them justifying
themselves like it's Purity yeah and
they've got to be pure come on you want
to like you know don't think about this
and that just bust it out this is this
is just be what you're like I think
that's old school if you ask me that was
just old school gay you know [ __ ]
trying because you couldn't say that you
couldn't come out and say it yeah
you didn't say that right so which is
another thing that's much better about
nowadays because now everybody can just
be like just whatever yeah okay No One's
Gonna complain I don't think the church
was
100 it wasn't really like anti-gay in
the way that people think because I
think a lot of the church was actually
produced by gay dudes the artwork and
there's some of it especially the
officially the Renaissance period
no it's gay dudes man running at church
the best the best art and entertainment
and stuff like that is pretty not just
by game just by weirdos in general yeah
weirdos in general so it's just or
people that are outside of the
mainstream yeah if you just let
mainstream people do your art and [ __ ]
like that it's kind of boring it's gonna
suck yeah it's good well it's gonna be
boring it's gonna be
I think the church was partially you
need weirdos like to spice [ __ ] up yeah
and like they they knew that but they
didn't want to admit it so it's like
they had to come up with all these
convoluted justification I'm not sure
they had the cultural context they did
it they did it the dudes may have been
gay and not really understood what it
was that they were feeling they were
trying to Holy eyes it and flip it
around and be make it into something
that that was acceptable to their moral
system you know what I mean although
they must have been having sex with
dudes and boys
yeah because we're keeping Boys around
them yeah
well it's speculated that a lot of the
great artists of that time I mean it's
been speculated about uh eventually
Michelangelo
um you know Caravaggio there's a lot of
homoerotic Art and stuff for sure
because you couldn't show
heterosexual Eros
but they never explained why
they said well it's wrong
so
the homosexual erotic stuff that's right
well [ __ ] now you're taking it back to
the ancient Greeks yeah because that's
what they believed well it was classic
it was classy [ __ ] so that's what
intelligent people did they're they're
getting away from that dirty straight
stuff that's just about sex and
reproduct this is high-minded stuff this
is about philosophy so that's what they
were talking about I think they were
just putting it in a Christian context
yeah yeah so they could always find
reasons for doing what I mean that's
kind of working you have to yeah that's
what people do and you have to
understand the context of the time you
justify like what you already wanna
you're right yeah you already want to
believe you have to make it acceptable
within the framework that you're given
you're trying to like well most people
psychologically they're trying to paint
themselves in the best possible light
so whatever it is that you think even if
you know like what you're doing or
saying or whatever is shitty
you're gonna try and like justify it
somehow
unless you're a total sociopath
but most people will try to justify her
to find like an excuse for it so I kind
of feel like that's why and in the
context of the time because being gay
was not acceptable and it wasn't really
like widely understood so they had to
come up with some convoluted explanation
I think it depended on a period though
it did though it did because I think in
the Renaissance period I think it was
open for a while especially the monks I
don't know about open but it didn't it
was like an Open Season yeah let's call
it that they weren't it was like a
reaction against that that was depending
if you had money right but that's kind
of always been the case if you had money
you could kind of get away with anything
yeah because people are like what we're
just being you know at the Forefront of
culture we're not doing anything crazy
yeah it's always been like that if
you're a poor [ __ ] you you'd you know if
you were doing that [ __ ] then it was
like
then you're gonna get in trouble but you
know rich people could get away with
anything as usual especially if they
were nobility sure
you know and that's been truth like
throughout history
rules only applied to poor people
yeah
keeping him [ __ ] in line
so uh so let's talk a little bit about
because I want to get into a little bit
about
um the whole assassination thing a
little bit and um into the the sun's uh
really entertaining cult but uh there
were there have been many controversies
obviously about the unification church
since its founding but you know
since it kind of like went mainstream in
the 70s
um
one of the controversies obviously uses
my you know mind control or brainwashing
which like I said it utilizes a lot of
the same techniques that a lot of uh
other Cults use love bombing uh
isolation cutting you off from families
yada yada
um and some of the members that escaped
later on said that um you know they were
oppressed in various ways or abused in
various ways so they're doing kind of
like the same stuff that Cults were
doing
also as I said it uh maintains a very
large amount of front companies of
various kinds that you would not know
were associated with the religion unless
you dug deep down and uh you know
researched it
um also they have been accused of being
connected with the South Korean
intelligence agency the kcia
and uh basically they're trying to uh
they've also been accused of basically
trying to take over the world like I
said and try to start like a theological
One World Government which
good luck it's that well yeah good luck
with that I mean it sounds crazy but
that does seem like what they're trying
to do I don't think they're going to
succeed in doing it but that does seem
to be their stated goal they do
Scientology we've tried the same thing
that's what I'm saying well that's why I
kept getting Scientology vibes from this
even though this is way more christian-y
whereas Scientology is much more
corporatist but it's and the Catholics
got that for a while I think Western
World boy erased thank you that's what
that movie was called Yeah Boy erased
yeah yeah that's right that was it yeah
that was a good movie it's a good movie
yeah we saw in the theater actually
um but yeah I like that it's just like a
fun movie about a [ __ ] weird I mean
it's not fun I thought it was fun
dudes going through all this [ __ ]
[ __ ] but you know he makes it out it's
not they didn't do anything that bad
they didn't do anything bad to him it
was just a bunch of [ __ ] they put
him through
I liked it I thought it was a good movie
I did I was entertained I did too I was
laughing the whole time [ __ ] this in
the church then I throw a ridiculous the
[ __ ] the church people were doing I was
like what the [ __ ]
but to think well like I said the thing
about it though is that I didn't grow up
like this but
to me it always just seemed like I would
have been like really offended if my
parents had like sent me off to like
some camp that it's like hey we we
reject everything that you stand for and
we're just gonna send you this weird
Camp that's gonna like even if they
don't beat you up or anything they're
just gonna like negate your entire like
[ __ ] personhood and I was just like
yeah I don't like well I don't think
your sexuality is your whole personhood
well no but you know I'm just I'm using
that as like yeah what it really was is
that they thought they found out the kid
was gay they thought that was a problem
they thought they could fix it
yeah they sent to a prayer the Gateway
Camp run by gay people
it's [ __ ] who are like selfish yeah
who didn't know who did who did who were
trying to they were trying to like
they're trying to fix themselves too but
I guess but oh I was gay too but I got
over it yeah yeah yeah yeah it's it's
ridiculous you know it is it's a
ridiculous yeah
please don't send your children there I
mean nobody here would but I'm just
saying please don't do that to your
children that's awful Zach see it you'd
love it
I mean it's kind of it's kind of sad but
it's also like kind of funny in a black
like humorous kind of way well I don't
take that [ __ ] seriously they're just
well I mean it did really happen like
the guys like that it was a church group
though yeah it's not like a
concentration camp or a [ __ ] Mexican
prison
I don't know if this is still around or
not it's a summer camp but there was a
time
when I remember in the 80s and 90s when
there were some like of these kind of uh
Christian teen camps or whatever like it
wasn't prey the gay away necessarily but
it was just like if you had a kid that
you couldn't control like oh my God
they're listening to Slayer or they're
doing [ __ ] I don't like they're
teenagers and you could have yeah
they're they're teenagers essentially
and they could have this group come and
like kidnap the kid
like they come in a van literally they'd
come in advance yeah put a hood over the
kid's head and like take them away in
the van and like take them to this I'm
like
is that even [ __ ] legal apparently it
was like they could do that Scientology
did worse that's well yeah those kids
they put them in a damn [ __ ] Work
Camp because right they'd have them
there for [ __ ] years
cutting logs and [ __ ] like that yeah
cutting logs and seriously there's a
camera there's a great book you guys
there's a great book you guys yeah talk
about uh Scientology that's called
beyond belief yeah and it was written by
the niece of David miscavige who was
born in Scientology
and she tells some [ __ ] I seriously
like I teared up right into that book I
have it somewhere it's it's in my shelf
somewhere that was a [ __ ] horrifying
and I even knew like a lot of the [ __ ]
that Scientology was doing and that's
just like oh man what's a what a [ __ ]
bummer
Jesus Christ boy erased that's right
2013. yeah yeah I actually want to see
that one again now yeah that was good
yeah I liked it laughs
uh yeah so where was I okay so yeah so
so the Moonies are much like the
scientologists I don't think they'll
ever succeed but just the fact that they
want to like a [ __ ] super villain
they want to like take over the world
with their own
you know theological views or whatever
which I in no way endorse
so they want to do that
and uh also I should note too that
they've gotten in trouble with uh
various tax laws and stuff because of
course they don't pay [ __ ] taxes you
know they don't so 1982 matter of fact
um
Moon got convicted
of conspiracy to evade taxes and he
actually got sentenced to 18 months in
prison and he actually served 13 months
in prison
for tax evasion because of like 100 I
think it was like 162 000 or something
like that that he'll like pay taxes on
that he didn't report or something like
that
um also they tried to pull some Jim
Jones [ __ ] where they were trying to
start a big Community down in South
America and ended up buying some land
that belonged to some indigenous people
and he kind of like [ __ ] over the
indigenous people that were like farming
on that land it was like a whole thing
so there was that as well like I said
not not a great [ __ ] look kind of say
now as I mentioned before even though
Moon and his wife uh said they were and
his children
they had 13 13 or 14 I can't remember
but it was 13 or 14 kids
and they were supposedly the true family
they were like the ideal or whatever
even though they were portraying that
image to the world
um obviously you know there was some
shady [ __ ] going on behind the scenes
because there always is whenever you
have something like a facade like that
so one of the members
um who had been in from for like a long
time he wrote a book in 1993. and he
said basically that the Reverend Moon
had basically
he's like yeah well I have this family
with my wife and 13 or 14 kids however
many [ __ ] kids he had it was a lot
he was like
um I need to
contribute to
what he called the sexual restoration of
the world
by of course having sex with other women
and then all the other women that he had
sex with
they would have to like pass on the
restorative sex to six men each I think
that's how that math goes I don't know
so that's kind of like the the
arithmetic that he had going there
so there was that
also as I mentioned earlier
uh one of the women uh in 1998 who had
been married to
the Reverend Moon's eldest son
she came out she left the cult and she
came out and she said her husband was a
drug addict like on [ __ ] Coke and all
this other kind of stuff and uh had also
[ __ ] around on her like just [ __ ]
everything that moved and beat her up
while she was pregnant so there's that
also said that River Moon had several
illegitimate children
and
um basically that like a bunch of their
kids had like gotten the [ __ ] out of the
cult because they just weren't having it
or either that or they were like super
party kids much unlike the uh image that
they were trying to portray like in the
media
so there was that so a lot of people
kind of came out afterward I kind of
feel like there hasn't been anything as
high profile as people coming out of
Scientology and like saying what all the
crazy [ __ ] they were doing
but you know
what oh and evidently some heavy shits
happening in the inside Scientology
right now like what David miscavige and
[ __ ] [ __ ] happening down in
Clearwater uh legal problems and uh it
could be that that Scientology doesn't
have much time left I think you know
they're not growing
you know
well I kind of feel sure movies aren't
either like I said I kind of feel like
the internet
even though people could say like you
know the internet is also uh complicit
and like propagating a lot of
you know stupid like [ __ ]
misinformation and stuff like that yeah
that happens too but in a lot of ways I
feel like
Cults and this kind of belief system I
don't know if it's ever gonna die
completely because humans are humans but
you can approach it the same way as you
used to be able to back in the old days
because people aren't going to fall for
it anymore I think Cults are going to
evolve into other things well they
probably will they'll have to adapt yeah
and I don't think they'll be look they
won't look like religious groups it'll
be like philosophies and political ideas
I think
because you can get because you're not
they're not making claims
they're not making Supernatural claims
so it's a lot easier to get a hold of
people like that people have religious
instincts they need something to do with
them so if they're not in some kind of a
god-based religion they'll jump into a
damn political based religion or a
philosophy of some sort then you can
make money off of them that way or use
them as political armies
I mean [ __ ] it's just look at history
you know just the way it is
you're never going to change human
nature
and the same thing with bad information
if there's always been a mixture of bad
information we've always had yellow
journalism and [ __ ] newspapers that
lie and always and people have always
just consistently
chosen to believe what they wanted to
believe out of the information well
generally it's like you believe whatever
um confirms your already established
view so you're never going to control
people's belief which this is a
Herculean task
every dictator and every totalitarian
Society has tried to control what people
believe and it eventually always
backfires because you have to start
killing people when you do that
because you well and sometimes they do
what do you mean
no you had yeah no I said like the
original yeah yeah well they know they
eventually get to that right you don't
believe that we believe because that's
the only way that yeah and then that
comes back on them then that regime
fails you know because you can't run a
regime like that not for long
so
you just have to let people believe
whatever they want to believe if you
don't like it then just opt out
you know because this is the world this
is the way life is
and if you don't like it then you can
leave
we're all going to leave anyway
all right I mean the thing about it is
that I don't really have a problem with
people believing what they want to
believe it's just that when their
beliefs like cause them to do [ __ ] up
[ __ ] then then you gotta worry that's
the world but while it's still in their
brains then I don't give a [ __ ] about it
yeah well that's the world though you
know well duh I know yeah I mean you
know you're sitting there believing what
you want to believe in timogen and the
Mongolian horde come and just totally
[ __ ] rape pillage and kill everybody
in your town you know I mean that's just
because they believed what they believed
and that's just been that way since the
beginning yeah but that's exactly what I
just said when your beliefs cause you to
do [ __ ] up [ __ ] to other people then
we're gonna have a problem yeah as long
as it's still in your brain right then
no one's gonna have a problem with it
yeah it depends on what your point of
view because those guys didn't care that
you had a problem with it they killed
you and then replaced you with one of
their own but right but that's going
back to what why do I have to keep
repeating I'm not repeating I'm just
saying why do I have to keep repeating I
know just saying you're affecting other
people at that point yeah you're
affecting other people some people
believe that's the way to go in which at
which point you were going to get
pushback because
then it comes down to 50 because of
course right well [ __ ] is like outside
your brain now it's like we have to
fight back against you
part of animal nature you know what I
mean and humans are animals like all the
other animals and uh unfortunately until
uh until
we're all dead or
um human beings have now become
something that is now a cyborg in some
kind of a [ __ ] you know uh metaverse
then that's the way people are going to
be because
you just got to look at history and I
don't think the future is going to be
any different
from history
because I haven't seen any
anything different in modern people
versus ancient people other than the
technology and I don't know how
sustainable that is
because that requires a sophisticated
supply chain system that is not really
it might not be sustainable long term
so all right so unification Church in
2000 uh they were actually one of the
co-sponsors of the million family March
in DC uh along with the Nation of Islam
so there was that
uh May 2002 federal police in Brazil had
a bunch of raids on a lot of their front
organizations that were linked to Sun
Moon because he was still alive at that
point in Brazil uh yeah yeah
um they were doing a whole investigation
into the cult because of tax evasion
which like I said he got arrested here
for that and uh immigration violations
by church members so there was that as
well also he supported the government of
Argentina during the Falklands War so
that was uh something else that they
took issue with uh in 2003
Moon also started his uh Tear Down the
Cross campaign
uh so this I guess he started this
because he thought and this is kind of
funny because I kind of feel like a lot
of comedians have brought this up but
it's like you know if Jesus actually did
come back like one of these days he's
like the last thing he'd want to see is
a [ __ ] cross he's like hey I died on
that [ __ ] that shit's not funny so I
guess Moon took that like seriously so
he wanted to go around and tear down
crosses and replace them with crowns
because he was like yeah Jesus would
come back and not want to see the
crosses so he got some like traction
with that he got some media attention
with that
uh so there was that April 2008 moon was
88 years old and he actually appointed
his youngest son whose name was uh hyung
Jin moon to be the new leader of the
unification church and the worldwide
leader
that same year it should be said
um Sun uh hyung Jin Moon the youngest
son who is known as Reverend Sean
he actually got a huge amount of media
attention because he had one of those
big like blessing marriage ceremonies
uh in which everyone was encouraged to
bring AR-15s
and also everywhere he goes he wears a
gold crown made of bullets
um
so
he's a symbolism he took a tiny passage
in the Bible that said something about
Jesus with an iron Rod yeah and he
literally he's a crazy person he
literally interpreted that to mean that
Jesus
thousands of years ago
had an error 15. oh stop it which air
yeah he does they didn't have that yeah
well duh I know that he apparently does
not
um well for one error 15 isn't really
made of iron is it it's made of aluminum
aluminum and steel so yeah so that's
just dumb from the he's saying he's he's
thinking whoever wrote the Bible
predicted you know uh uh the the Advent
of firearms but I guarantee you that's
not what that's what he's saying but
that's not what he actually believes he
saw that passage that says it says this
is the passage I'm going to use to
justify us arming up
okay he has a gold-plated one and also
like I said a bullet Crown how the hell
do you play and he and he expects
everyone to take him seriously how the
hell do you play
alone and they had I don't know but he
has one and they had like a whole price
reappeared probably yeah it probably is
though if you went to like [ __ ] home
yes
the thing about it is that the church
that he started because of the
beliefs behind it
um it got a lot of uh Traction in let's
call it America's Heartland and I don't
think that people knew that it was the
Moonies okay now this what's this guy's
name again Sean no well he's just called
reverend Sean but his name is hyung-jin
Moon he has a thing called how many iron
Rod Ministries
and they have I saw there was a there's
a vice documentary on YouTube but
there's like a bunch of other stuff
about this where like a bunch of people
show up he can't have that many people
well I don't know like how many there
are well the thing about it and like I
said I kind of feel like even from back
in the 70s one of the Moonies things
that they would do is that they had all
these front groups that nobody knew were
the Moonies they didn't know that it was
like some weird like [ __ ] cult or
anything like that because it sounded
like
you know it's got to be what they it's
got to be a front group that they use
for recruitment to get to get more
muscle into the church guys that are
into guns maybe ex-military guys maybe
they thought that that might I guarantee
this wouldn't work I don't think it
would work well um I don't think I I
probably wouldn't get that man I would
tell you to go watch that Vice
documentary because it absolutely does
work how many members are there Vice
will tell you anything well I don't know
well no I've seen like other things
other than Vice too but it's like
there's there's probably it's a whole
thing there's probably a couple thousand
it's a whole thing there's probably a
couple thousand of them maximum but um
it sounds like you said a way of getting
you see a lot of a lot of churches
especially Christian churches
Christianity is essentially apocalyptic
they believe this cult is as well yeah
they believe in the end of the world
yeah so
um there's kind of a prepper mentality
always in Christianity yeah
so they probably think that it's a good
time for us to try to build up a
paramilitary force so when civilization
collapses our church Will Survive and
we'll be able to protect our own members
this isn't something that would be
um confined just to this group
scientology's like that guarantee
Scientology is a lot better for probably
equipped to survive the apocalypse and
these guys
um sign tells you have secret bases and
all kinds and evidently they have a lot
of gods but they keep them stored
um because you can buy them with church
money
see this is free money
you have to justify all this [ __ ]
to keep your tax-free status you have to
keep buying things you know
uh usually property but weapons you
could do that too
yeah you just have to write it down the
right way probably
explain it the right way but yeah I mean
as I mentioned uh please look up the
list of all the front companies that
they have because it's a lot
um you know and it's all over the
[ __ ] map like I said it's publishing
it's Fisheries it's like [ __ ] you
wouldn't even like think of yeah that
was owned by these [ __ ]
um and you wouldn't even know well
they're trying they have to expand
probably because well they've been doing
like like I said they've been doing that
since the 70s now are they tax free do
you know do they have the taxes um you
know what I'm not entirely sure I would
imagine they probably are because
they're a Christian denomination
they're not like I said they're not that
weird they're not that far off from
Chris from mainstream so usually what
ends up happening when you have to to
keep your tax-free status you have to
keep expanding the church you have to
start buying things
well I mean technically they're also not
supposed to get involved in like
politics and stuff but that doesn't seem
to stop them does it I don't know
are they politics yeah okay it doesn't
seem to stop them I think I think a
church member can give money right but
technically from a legal standpoint at
least in the United States yeah
um you know for like a pastor can't tell
his hey you should vote for this that
and the other they're not really
supposed to do that they do it I mean
they can but they're not supposed to
retain their tax exempt status if they
do that because you know they're
supposed to be separation of church in
the state but they all do it yeah I'll
do it anyway yeah and they and then they
do it uh different ways you know but
everybody does that
you know but
the United States is not is very
legalistic on one sense but everybody
breaks these laws so it doesn't really
matter
you know but it just does sort of the
[ __ ] they want but as I mentioned uh you
know not only do they have a ton of
front groups but like I said they also
give a lot of money to a bunch of other
groups that
this may you know maybe that also
Scientology gives money to
um one of the groups they give money to
is the American Conference on religious
movements which is also funded by
Scientology
uh the American Freedom Coalition which
is like a a real uh right-wing group
they also give money to the Christian
Heritage Foundation foundation for
Religious Freedom which is another
Scientology front group these are
usually big gangs of lawyers Liberty
University million family March uh
National conservative political action
committee committee those are um their
main like uh ones that they give money
to
and like I said Scientology gives a lot
of money to those as well so as I
mentioned like uh the rubber Moon died
in 2012.
now after that happened like his wife
was still alive
um hak Jahan moon now she was kind of
seen as the I guess secondary Messiah so
she was like the mother of humankind so
she kind of went off on her little way
which I'm sure wasn't all that much
better but she's kind of like seen as
like the you know she founded like a
couple of groups of her own but like I
said her sons kind of went off on the
other offshoot now the youngest one that
founded
The Sanctuary Church that's what they
call it for short he was the one that
does like he still does the wedding
ceremonies but now he's like everybody
show up in the wedding clothes but also
bring your gold-plated AR-15 and your
bullet crowns and they have like I saw
the pictures and the videos of like all
the people that came to that I'm like
rounds can't look cool they don't they
don't look cool though no I mean
foreign
the hilarious thing I saw somebody like
interviewing him yeah he's got a bullet
and he's wearing the crown and I'm just
like how can she keep a strap face keep
a straight face like talking to this
[ __ ] because he's like very
serious like talking now the bullet
Crown is it is it linked ammunition like
out of a belt-fed machine gun with
pretty much yeah it kind of looks like
that but then it has like a like a
symbol kind of thing in them I can't
remember what it is but it's like a
round thing in the middle but then like
all around that yeah it kind of looks
like belt them machine but it's like
gold-plated okay and I was just kind of
like
because she actually like didn't just be
like it had to be something okay it had
to be something like they told him says
well you're gonna have to make your own
denomination of the church because we
got to spread out and we got to [ __ ]
hide money here and there because you
eat they're doing I mean it really does
seem like they're doing that when when
you're a religion you can't hoard money
uh studying Scientology and how they do
things Scientology has all kinds of
problems because they have too much
money they're gonna do stuff with it
probably what they did I wish that was a
problem that I had yeah they got too
much and and it's all tax-free you know
what I mean so they have to be they have
to be boohoo they have to be a church
and churches have to have some kind of a
justification so they probably told him
that look man we got all this we got all
this money and
you've got to form a church former your
own church what kind of church do you
want he goes I like gods so I'm gonna
make a church of the Gods and they okay
and then he goes through the scripture
and he goes okay this is God you're a
rod of iron church so that's probably
all it is you have to come up with a
with a with uh everybody likes Gods I'll
hand out [ __ ] AR-15s and we'll buy
them with church money although to be
fair like I've listened to him talk and
he does sound like a crazy person he
doesn't well they're of course they're
crazy he sounds like of course they're
crazy
they're in they're in the church
business like I get like like I've never
[ __ ] met anybody in the church
business and that's what I call it it is
a church business well clearly and this
is
that was that that was saying no they're
really not no they're really not normal
but this guy really does seem to believe
his own [ __ ] which is crazy which is
crazy
because it's like so transparently
ridiculous he's a preacher though
preacher's [ __ ]
no you didn't [ __ ] southern baptist
ministers in [ __ ] Mississippi Dave
[ __ ] full of [ __ ] you know same dude
so I can sitting there doing all the
fire and brimstone is the same dude
that's [ __ ] your wife
it's him well Dad everybody he's the one
who's [ __ ] your wife yeah everybody
knows they're full of [ __ ]
so uh before we go I did want to mention
uh as I said I think kind of everybody
had a little bit forgotten about the
Moonies until 2022 when uh the former
Japanese prime minister Shinzo Abe was
assassinated and the guy that
assassinated him whose name was uh
tetsuya yamagami
actually he said that he assassinated
him because Ave was
um
kind of like friendly to the unification
church and he was saying that his mom
like the Assassin's mom yeah
um actually was forced to make a big
donation to the church because she had
joined in 1998 and she sold a bunch of
the land that she inherited from her dad
um and the house where you know he lived
when he was growing up like as a kid
and she donated like 720 000 to the
unification church back then and like
the family went into bankruptcy and so
he was a little bit pissed about that
that sounds awful convoluted so what a
convoluted well he was um well he was
actually going to he was planning on
shooting the guy who was the head of the
church at the time okay
um and the former prime minister because
he'd been friendly to the church too but
he didn't get around to the second guy
you know what I mean he just like shot
the first guy yeah so I think well I'm
just saying that he made a homemade pipe
gun I brought that yeah he made a gun
but he like I brought that up because
that kind of like brought
um the Moonies like back into the media
again because I feel like even though
they've been working behind the scenes
this whole [ __ ] time because like I
said they got all kind of like political
influence and all kind of little
companies going on back there that
people don't know about but
um they had kind of like fallen out of
prominence like until that assassination
happened and then everybody like started
talking about them again you know what I
mean like in 2022 so I wanted to bring
that up like before we got to get drunk
I got like [ __ ] man I got that [ __ ]
curry chicken that Thai curry chicken
down there waiting to just be heated up
what do you think about that I think
that's a good idea we should probably do
that the rice we should probably do that
okay
so I think this came out to be like a
good show right yeah a decent show did
you guys enjoy the show
I know I'm getting hungry okay I'll make
something go ahead and shut it down all
right so we will be back on Friday
evening for our side track show so
hopefully you can come by and see us
then thank you everybody for coming by
and listening to us Chit Chat thank you
for all your super chats thank you for
your continued support you guys are
awesome and we'll see you again Friday
evening
good night